there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey we are back once again
for another episode this is 151 yeah
going back to Korea for this one yeah
going back a true-crime for this one it
really seemed like everybody enjoyed our
one hundred and fiftieth episode last
week that I had to break up three pizzas
we weren't really planning on that but
we were having technical difficulties we
yeah yeah we weren't sure if certain
files were corrupted so we were just
loaded yeah because I did it all in one
go that was like three and a half hours
and the file got corrupted and we didn't
record until like late usually I record
like way ahead of time but we kind of
like got busy and I didn't we didn't get
to do it till later so I didn't really
have time to process the whole thing out
over again so I just did it in three
shorter parts just so I could get it up
in time and it was a little bit late but
not really yeah but yeah we noticing
that shutters now running ads on her
well one that I just saw yeah yeah now
that we're monetized I'd like to have
miss direct sponsor well guess we're not
big enough I'm on me with that shot or
money maybe one of these days some of
that shutter money cuz like I said it's
not even like really whoring because
yeah I actually really like shudder yeah
and it's a really good service and its
really yeah you know I use BOTS or
shudder with honor as long as they
didn't tell you what to say
yeah which is far as I know they don't
cuz I but I've seen a couple of a couple
of channels like movie review channels
that I subscribe to
yeah half shudder as a direct sponsor
like I said although they usually have
like a million subscribers or more um
and as far as I know they don't seem
like they well now that now that we're
monetized maybe they'll move us up the
show seems to be growing again so I
guess that the algorithms are not I
think not as against us as they were
before we were monetized well like I
said that's what we wanted to that's
what we wanted to accept
we don't our content isn't political or
controversial so I don't see why they
wouldn't promote us you know yeah I mean
we're just talking about weird murders
and like old horror movies and stuff you
know yeah everybody likes this [ __ ] yeah
I would think I mean every now and then
you get some like asshat in the comments
but you can just take one of them I just
take them off because you know like I
said my motto in life is if I want your
opinion I'll ask for it
and to that is I will not ask for it so
keep it to your damn self yeah you don't
want to show don't watch it sounds like
you're being forced to why that's what I
mean it's not like there's not millions
of other option it's not like you paid
money to watch this right that's what
kills me but it's like that's what kills
me about some of the comments not so
much on ours because we don't really get
that many bad ones do it sometimes I see
ones on other videos that I'm watching
I'm like why do [ __ ] this is free
info - yeah it's like why you find
something you do like yeah storming
outside see people there who are bed and
down listening to us before bedtime
you're gonna have that storm action
going in the background you might as
well you might even put up put on one of
those little lightning [ __ ] yeah
things upon what you know it's put that
up on your Smart TV give you some
atmosphere yeah cuz we're gonna talk
about some more crime I guess start
drinking yeah guys my cool calm because
for us it's Saturday night and that's
like I said we live in Central Florida
and pretty much every evening in the
summer it storms storms or rains and yet
it's so hot so that even a clubbing
isn't really that good yeah you know I
like it better than in winter well yeah
because then you can wear like all your
oh no I think I wore a coat one time
it's just it's alright so before we get
into the topics this week got a couple
of shout out shout outs cuz we got a
couple of new patrons yeah now we had a
patron named Amanda and she drastically
increased her support so that's pretty
cool she's gonna be getting a shirt as
well
yeah I'm up printer up or share tomorrow
yeah and we'll send him out in the next
day or so yeah cuz we got we're
packaging it all up and yeah I got all
the packages
I got all the packages addressed and you
know little notes on them like there's
some other guy I got a big a big guy he
who was that he got hit a 2xl yeah sure
we had to go get that on a special run
because her three XL or three XL he's
getting a slightly different shirt his
is gonna be a hunter set cotton it's a
nice shirt but you know I mean that was
the only three XL that was available
yeah it's black but it's gonna be all
copy I mean they're all pretty much the
same which are certain advantages to
that you can read I that [ __ ] with RIT
as long as you want it'll it'll stay
looking brand new forever I know yeah
yeah so Amanda increased her patreon
money so that was awesome and we also
got two new patrons Victor and Jeanette
so thank you very much and welcome to
the show we're very glad you found us it
seems like we've got it like a lot of
new people that are just kind of coming
across this I got a lot of comments like
for the last couple videos cuz we got
monetized maybe maybe we're coming up
and more people suggested but that's
what we wanted so you're right we just
want more people to check out the show
yeah cool all right so what I wanted to
do on this show I wanted to talk about
two cases that they I feel like they're
not really that well-known in the United
States and there's really not a lot of
information about them in English and
since I can't speak Korean it was kind
of hard for me to like find stuff about
it about them I actually started
thinking about her reading about the one
case of the Frog Boys which I'm going to
talk about in the second segment and
that was for my book that's gonna be
coming out the faceless villain vol 3
but while I was looking into that I
found this other serial killer over
there - that's like never been caught
now also the killer of the frog voice
has never been caught either so these
are two unsolved crimes from Korea and
the first one that we're going to talk
about in the first segment is called the
wasps young serial killer yeah thus far
unidentified yeah for those you guys
knew the show I was stationed in Korea
and I thought you would have some good
Korean stories and they I got all kinds
of Korea's
well that's good I was stationed in
Korea during the first Gulf War you know
when I I went to basic training in the
infantry at Sand Hill outfit 254 that's
where all the infantry trains that trade
was actually to go to the first Gulf War
but by the time my class or my cohort
graduated they had a thing where they
were doing like stop losses and weird
stuff like that we were too late so they
didn't send us instead they sent us to
the first and the 506 which is up there
near that DMZ in Korea which was worse
that was hard
yeah but never that was harder than
going to the sandbox because just
because the cold cold the heat intense
just brutal discipline it's just one
regiment the 1st battalion 3 1st
battalion and the 5 list the 1st
battalion 500 6th Infantry it's a camp
grieves which is right near warrior base
where the other guys do their patrols
and we were kind of like the DMZ
Regiment detachments from us ran those
worked with JSA and Liberty Bell was
part of our unit too so you know they
hold the talks where a couple weeks ago
Trump went across the border with with
kim jeong-hoon that's near where i
worked so i know that whole area I know
guys that worked there and those blue
buildings with a holdat oxide I knew the
way I know everything about how that
[ __ ] was run back in the 90s it's
changed a bit
you know the guard posts are different
than everything but Korea was a wild
place man in the 90s it was real wild
and it's time to down a lot a lot of
things have changed the military
situation is different the economy is
different the Koreans are a lot more
wealthy people than they used to be
versus the 90s you know they've rival
Japan now in terms of economic
development but not back in these this
day back in the days I'm talking about
in the 90s they were still kind of stuck
in the 70s I would say yeah anyways they
were behind and then pour a lot of
government backed prostitution going on
and weird [ __ ] like that but it Itaewon
was called hooker hill which is weird
where they were kind of like recruiting
poor girls into an army of prostitutes
to serve
the American army and the Korean army to
get as much money out of the American
army as possible to get it into the
Korean economy they were almost
considered like Patriots finally for
every dollar they could get out of a GI
and it was just
you're just beset by [ __ ] a whole
army of basically seventeen to twenty
five year old girls and women you know
and they're from you know I guess they
were from developing families in Korea
but it was just it had this weird
atmosphere murders did happen there and
regarding this you know I mean
prostitutes were killed sometimes they
had weird [ __ ] going on almost kind of
like military concubinage going on in
certain areas it was just a weird time
and this these murders happened after
all this
well not but not for not long after well
the wasps young serial murders happened
between 1986 and 1990 welcome okay yeah
we're a few more later that they are not
sure if it's the same person or not okay
and I think the Frog boy's case also
happened in 91 okay so this is the same
arrow that's about the same time they
were there I thought was after but yeah
okay that's the same error I'm talking
about it was the Wild West and we're
gonna get into details but from what I
know about the case so far based on what
Jenny's told me huh I'm kind of I'm kind
of suspect that there could have been
American involved in this maybe leprosy
yeah I think I told you about the Frog
boy's case because I knew that you had
been in Korea at about that time and I
had wondered if you heard about it
because it was apparently like a really
big and the Hiwassee on serial killer
case is also a very big deal I mean like
that meant like a whole bunch of movies
about it and TV shows and stuff but I
feel like it hasn't really filtered
through to the West so much but I
wondered it because I knew you were over
there at that time like I wondered if
you had heard anything about it because
I heard it was kind of no I was so busy
we didn't hear about anything about
what's going outside the unit I didn't
the whole time I was there I only got
maybe 10 days off maybe 12 and your
for a while right here a year a year
yeah every month I got maybe one 24-hour
pass yeah and I had a report right back
they didn't want the guys from my unit
to be out from underneath their thumb
for very long other guys at Casey they
kind of have normal lives when they they
got off at night you know they could do
whatever they wanted and they had a life
in town and girlfriends my unit was run
like a maximum-security military prison
is almost what it was like you're there
on that damn border they're constantly
keeping you down busy we're kind of know
we're known you can look it up we were
called the em gym Scouts the Scouts
across the MGM river and you know
there's there's whole there's a whole
industry of making patches and
medallions and coins for our unit it's a
very famous unit you know the 506 was if
you've ever heard of the yourself movie
the band of brothers or actually it was
a series right band of brothers yeah
that is about my unit yeah yeah Kirti
mountain and all that yeah so but you
know the they broke us off from 101st
and attaches to the 2nd Infantry
Division and had us up there on that
border
I think they first moved it there in the
Vietnam era or right after the Vietnam
era it's not there anymore
yeah the 506 is back with 101st now and
if I got out of that unit I went to the
hundred first but anyway all that shit's
academic I know the I know the landscape
of what they're talking about and the
society that they're talking about it
was Korea was in a weird transition at
that time it was a modern country but
only kinda it was in a state of military
dictatorship kinda which might have
contributed to some of the police yeah
why why the serial killer wasn't caught
and it was a military dictatorship
because things were happening kind of
like under the stress of war you know
North and South would have been in it
basically this war going back to the 50s
you know it was hard to trust democracy
because South Korea may have been
heavily infiltrated there was a lot of
North Koreans spies working inside South
Korea there was a bunch of weird [ __ ]
going on at that
and then Korea culture the Koreans at
that time are kind of coming out of
thousands of years of abuse between the
Chinese and the Japanese you know they
were kind of an abused population and it
kind of had a medieval mentality that
they were kind of getting out of like
like I said selling girls into
concubinage and they did [ __ ] like that
still yeah and and then they just kind
of had these weird situations where they
thought that was normal but then when
the girl was like now an ex concubine or
next prostitute she was now unacceptable
so she was treated like garbage well
yeah so it's always weird double
standards you know can't win they would
know it would take these pretty girls
you know and train them to speak English
and have American customs the government
would basically back turning them into
an army of entertainers yeah get as much
money as they could out of these like
Geisha culture basically yeah but they
were kind of they were kind of aping
Western society like you know it would
get up wearing bikinis dressed like a
cowgirl with pistols and [ __ ] you know
what I mean they're dancing in clubs
like that with American flags you know
you knew it was going on yeah can I just
say though that prostitute army would be
a really cool yeah for a female punk
band you could guys can research it that
we didn't know what was going on at the
time as young soldiers yeah it seemed to
be kind of like a normal thing that was
happening but not was a show all put on
by the Korean government for us get as
much money out of the American
government as possible yeah cuz the guy
I couldn't spend enough money there
because I only got like one day off a
month I made a lot of money
yeah just piled up yeah but guys that
had more normal type jobs they went out
six days a week you know what I mean
they were partying hard they spent all
their paycheck in Korea yeah yeah well
yeah spending it on Club girls and
spending it on booze and candled and
kettles [ __ ] booze they had this
stuff called so would you and they'd mix
it with [ __ ] priest
kool-aid powder in a big like a TKO I
know what you're talking about yeah yeah
one tea kettle of that [ __ ] was only
about $2 and that would [ __ ] up five men
Oh
seemed like it economical yeah it was it
was a weird mixture of good and bad
moving backwards in time like life in
just like something you'd see from out
of the 40s World War two yeah or you
know or it's what it seemed like yeah it
was hardcore but yeah that's all gone
now that you legalized don't let you
yeah I'm talking on now that's kind of a
good background though because I feel
like like I said um this serial killer
who has never been caught he's also
called the Wong strangler um the
interesting thing is that South Korea
has always been you know one of the
lowest crime nations in the world so
they don't have a lot of serial killers
as far as I know the wasps young
strangler was not necessarily the first
quote/unquote serial killer as in same
person killed more than one person but
it was the first one to have an
established MO where like all the
victims were clearly the victims of the
same killer you know what I mean yeah
but the weird thing about it because and
this kind of ties back into what you
were saying about you know them being
like under a military dictatorship there
was a lot of cops were kind of like one
they didn't have all the technological
advances they were kind of like backward
they didn't have I mean even when they
had DNA they knew about DNA and they
knew about collecting it but they didn't
have any way of testing it they had to
send it to Japan to do it and also there
was kind of like a lot of people who
were protesting against you know the
dictatorship and so the cops like a lot
of them were kind of tasked with
suppressing protesters and weren't
really interested in investigating a
serial killer especial
because it was in sort of a rural area
yeah so there was that kind of whole
thing going on - hold on one second I
got to speak in defense of South Korea
though when an American hears of
military dictatorship they're thinking
they think of [ __ ] like the Third Reich
or something like that you know I mean
that's not really the way the
dictatorship in Korea was the
dictatorship in Korea was more the Korea
efficiently was like a democratic
republic like the United States but it
was under the stress of war and a bunch
of emergency [ __ ] had kicked in you know
I mean it was because there were a bunch
of protests and there was I don't know
every all the little details but it
ended Korea in the 90s and for a long
time looked kind of like the United
States during World War two
it was so heavily heavily militarized
that everything kind of merged into a
government entity young Tama
during World War two you couldn't
protest World War two you'd end up going
to jail you couldn't defect or be a or
say you know or dodge the draft in World
War two they shot you you know you had a
democratic republic in the United States
during that time but all of them were
basically in agreement about the war all
of them were agreement in all that kind
of this draconian security apparatus
that was going on in the United States
South Korea was like that oh yeah it was
like a democracy that had decided to
temporarily give up democracy until
until the until the war was over it's
that kind of a mentality yeah you know
but whatever weren't really resist in it
you know I mean they weren't captured
what I'm saying was that you know
they're and they even like the several
movies that have been made about this
particular killer also kind of go into
this a little bit as well that that was
the reason why a lot of police forces
were short-handed also they weren't
really ER with this type of crime
because they didn't really see it all
that much and like I said they're you
know their technology was a few years
behind
you know even say Japan or whatever yeah
and Korea is kind of like Japan in a
certain way where everything's really
highly structured everything there's a
huge military type chain of command and
it's very bureaucratic and it's all
staff fully yes men young Tom about yeah
sometimes a guy might do something to
protect a boss or you know the mean they
would they would it's hard to get
anything done there cuz they're all
covering each other's asses right they
were all afraid of shaming a superior
that kind of [ __ ] well yeah because they
have the same type of thing like a lot
of Asian cultures had a thing where you
have to like you so they're always
always yeah a costly saving face so and
they have code they have these weird
cultural values where lying is okay yeah
no no man it's okay to lie cuz there are
good lies and bad lies right you know I
mean so it's very frustrating for two
for a westerner to try to figure what
the [ __ ] going on and get down to the
bottom of truth when you have people
that are lying right now they might lie
because cultural reasons make them lie
because they have to save face or that
kind of [ __ ] right I got yen right I
mean you know like I said it said all
cultures are complicated from a point of
view of someone that it didn't yeah it's
like that it's like that show we saw
that every show where an all Chinese
woman is getting a message from the
doctors that she's got terminal oh yeah
see that movie that's but they lie to
her because in a neck in that culture
you don't tell the truth somebody that
is there like that there died yeah
here they say bet you times up you gonna
die yeah like if you want to do anything
but you better do [ __ ] line yeah they're
like right you're well you're right it's
exactly what they don't do you so
there's a lot of that kind of stuff in
Korea he actually looks kind of
interesting because I'm interested about
like the cultural differences between
because though I mean the main character
I can't remember the name of it is but
um you know the main character is
someone who's like Chinese but she's
like westernized and then she goes back
to China and then there's like she
there's this whole culture clash between
you know probably we should tell her
that she's dying and they're like no we
can't he's doing brewing her good mood
you guys have totally different value
systems right exactly
Oh
okay Japan is considered to be almost
like an alien country that has weird
tradition compare Japan is Western
compared to Korea at the back in those
days Kanna almost is almost as as
Eastern as China was like be an inch
like a yam more modernized version of
China you know it was kind of like that
yeah China with money yeah but not as
much as Japan you know yeah although now
I like I said I think they rival Japan
in terms of wealth yeah I'd yet South
Korea sure um now the interesting thing
about the Hawass young serial killer
like I said there have been a million
movies about this probably the
best-known one is called memories of
murder it came out in 2003 I believe and
it was directed by bong joon-ho which if
you're into horror movies you will
recognize his name because he directed
the host he directed snowpiercer he did
the Netflix original oak Joe which I
haven't seen yet so he's like a really
big deal like you know horror director
and he made a movie about this I think
it was only his second movie he did
barking dogs never bite before this one
would which i think is either on shudder
or Netflix at the moment but this one is
not now this one I watched this movie
actually in preparation for the show you
can rent it from YouTube for 399 or
actually I found a free one on there so
if you want to find it before and watch
it for free before anybody takes it down
but it's a little bit of fictionalized
kind of thing but it's actually a really
really good movie and I'm gonna
recommend it if you dug David Fincher's
movie zodiac then you will probably love
this one it's like a police procedural
except kind of like a black comedy too
now interestingly this movie gets
compared to zodiac a lot but it actually
came out four years before zodiac but
it's a similar type of vibe and it's
kind of all about this particular killer
like I said some aspects of it are
fictionalized but it concentrates on the
cops and like how one they're kind of
inept - they kind of enjoy torturing
suspects - getting confessions out of
them which might have really happened
I'm not
sure new Korea yeah there oh yeah yeah
there's one actually there's one cop in
particular and he has kind of like a
redemptive arc you know as the movie
goes on but he has this mistaken belief
that he can just tell you're a killer by
looking in your eyes yeah thank you yeah
some kind of like magical thinking type
thing so he's picking up like all of
these and it's really sad because one of
the first people that they pick up in
the movie is like this mentally
challenged guy who they basically like
hang him upside down and they beat the
crap out of him and they try to like
coax him into confessing which they do
but he doesn't understand what he's
confessing to and he's like well I just
looked at just because he was ugly he
had like burns on the side of his face
and he wasn't that smart so he must have
done it right even though but they had
like the clash between that cop and then
there was one that had come from Seoul
that was kind of more like ahead of the
curve and like I do like how actual
investigation worked and so there was
like a fight between those two cops it's
actually a really good movie and I
recommend yeah that's actually weird
even for Korea yeah you can look into
somebody's eyes okay now I'm gonna
straighten something out for people that
don't know Korea real well you would
think that Korea would be something like
Buddhist or animist or some [ __ ] like
that like in like in Japan you know
they're not they're Christian yeah I
think they're Presbyterian or know some
kind of a Baptist type religion and what
was strange about that is that during
the Korean War they saw Douglas
MacArthur as like their big Savior
because he did save their country from
the north I mean that that's yes they
did the North took almost all of it
MacArthur did a big invasion at Incheon
and drove them all back out you know it
helped South Koreans regain power there
right well they all just adopted his
religion so I forgot which one it was if
you go to Korea it's like Christian
churches yeah Reverend we're gonna do a
show on Reverend moon oh those people
don't know what Muniz were
moenay's work people like ice know what
whoa moenay's were they're still around
yeah moenay's were Korean Christians
that they had their own Reverend and
they
went off cottony went off kind of like
the Mormons but it was more about
paranormal you know yeah Reverend moon
would absolutely project and go out and
fight communism and [ __ ]
ya know so we got to talk about that or
these day things I still remember that
mass wedding I think they had that on TV
he had this mass wedding and everybody
had it was all interracial marriages
whites and Koreans and blacks and whites
and whites and blacks and Koreans and
everything that was gonna I guess
balance out the harmony well he was
trying to unify trying to unify all the
human race yeah yeah even these a trip
though that is that's so crazy I'm not
[ __ ] crazy
I'm not just if I mentioned my nice idea
but you know Jim Jones had some nice
ideas too until he went flying the rails
we should do a show about that too the
thing is about every moon is that room
I'm gonna say this
from what I've know from what I know
there may be [ __ ] I don't know yet I
haven't really looked in from so far
Reverend moon was not a malevolent
character he was a good guy them start
out like that I don't think he did
anything bad though maybe real estate
scandals they were known all those
religion
real estate scams that's the thing like
I said even Jim Jones started out with
good intentions and then that [ __ ] just
got completely subverted and I think the
movie I think the moves still have a
[ __ ] ton of money actually I think they
do because like I said I think that's
still kind of a big deal like it going
like you don't see him in the airports
anymore not anymore not that I know of
last time yeah don't hang out with the
tambourines and most religions get
involved in real estate that's where
they sink their money into its best way
to do you just keep buying Seidenberg a
purser you just keep buying property and
say it's part of the church and that
it's all tax-free and you can't a lot of
weird well especially in this country
yeah you can yeah you can build a huge
empire if you say that your church okay
we got to do that Church Church of Tom
and Jenny means that's what I mean it's
like I don't don't think I haven't
thought property it's like yeah I can
buy all this just like yeah I'll buy all
that [ __ ] yeah pay taxes on it I can run
Winokur
you can like you could run a [ __ ]
religious brothel you can have your
masta to d'Armes in there it's like back
it's like back in the old Greek and
Roman times when they had like the
sacred yeah the sacred hooker is he an
awakened by the Templar road a man
inside Scientology has secret desert
basis they do huge concrete walls and
with all their plaques stored in their
their machine guns and all kinds of [ __ ]
guys going crazy up in there working by
themselves hanging themselves yeah can't
take it you wouldn't even like think
that was real just it was to hide the
put the plaques so they survive the end
of the world you can come out and bring
l ron Hubbard's teaching I think I
probably said this on one of our
Scientology shows when the angry gay
Pope was on but I was just like it
depresses me so much that if any kind of
like worldwide Cataclysm kind of
happened in like a whole psychology
would survive that's like the only thing
and then like that are like ah that bums
me out a lot the world isn't like people
want to think it is you know the things
that actually survive or [ __ ] like
cockroaches sharks and Scientology yeah
and GNC as a mall died yes Sonny we're
involved in bath and buy worst somebody
loves that [ __ ] lotion that's right
let it go to eat dine mall and you're
gonna the last one to die is Jan see
yeah for Savion body works some of them
still have Victoria's Secrets
yeah because their product doesn't cost
anything it must be that it's just all
profit it must be there because I just
always wondered why it's like every time
we see a dead ball video I'm like okay
well all the stores are closed where's
the GNC oh there it is
yeah the GNC is always still open yeah
always the last one standing and in my
props to you GNC in my personal
experience my personal observations I
mean you know you could lie to yourself
all you want it's not that ideally
high-minded [ __ ] that makes it over time
it's [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] that [ __ ] will
just gonna be around forever I think it
depends I mean it's not always stupid
[ __ ] that survives sometimes it's like
cool intelligence should because I mean
you know no some [ __ ] that up well okay
well you just see what you want to say
well think of what happens think what
happens if okay we all know that
civilizations earlier
kind of a thing as things get more
complicated it takes more to keep that
going you know civilizations have risen
and followed many times over if we ever
got hit by a big asteroid you know ten
thousand years in the future wiped out
civilization but a few people survived
they would not remember any of this you
wouldn't have physics and you know and
you know the works of Albert Einstein
and Chaucer all that [ __ ] would be long
gone but they would know they'd be more
worried about how to make fire well I
think given enough time they would
probably figure it out again it would
take a long time yeah but yeah it might
take us just as long as it did the first
but all that real sophisticated stuff
like the Sistine Chapel and all that
stuff and maybe that pyramid might still
be around because that was some dumb
[ __ ] to these a pile a bunch of rocks
together
that's pretty caveman thinking when you
think about it let's make it put them a
bit Rock stack those rocks up just keep
keep stacking them yeah until we get to
the top it was a bad investment man hey
you know after they built that when they
stopped I don't think they built anymore
you're like okay that was the pyramid to
end all pyramids I mean there's some
older ones out there they're all [ __ ]
up falling over because he can do them
right but you know yeah true but
advanced some of the early ones were
kind of lumpy yeah they're still there
yeah they eventually perfected those
three down there and the gating the gays
they called it quits they're just like
yeah we've yeah there's too much trouble
and religious it [ __ ] we'll just
write things down in a book yeah I
really think that's what they were doing
became rather more efficient ya know
yeah you know I think they built those
for the King more than it was religions
maybe bit
well yes we'll get into another day I
got a bunch of different ideas different
we got you got a we're talking about
pyramids now and this supposed to be
about Korea okay we're going on one her
side everybody loves it when I started
going on these little [ __ ] side and
sometimes like when I try to pay back
like you know later on like when I watch
this back to edited I'm always kind of
like curious because sometimes you know
I'm kind of
not thinking around reading my notes or
whatever while you're talking so
sometimes I'd be like wait how how did
we end up over here I don't even
remember how we did it up there you know
what I mean it doesn't matter it doesn't
really matter I'll talk about here of
his one time class something to look
forward to I was in Egypt too you know I
mean so yeah so he knows yeah I know you
know was in the Army I was in the MFO
mission multinational force below
reservist in the hundred first we were
working for the UN I got some stories
I'm hanging out with the Bedouin bed a
tween I got pictures of me with a little
better we know children oh yeah I've
seen those back yeah driving around in a
patrol truck [ __ ] with the AWACS
planes enforcing that embargo on a rock
all that [ __ ] no that [ __ ] added up to
being anything yeah it's all temporary
but yeah they built they built those
pyramids I don't want to talk about the
pyramids we're gonna talk about Korea
well you're the one that when I'm
talking about pyramids I'm [ __ ]
drinkin then he then he acts like it was
my idea yeah courage I'm just sitting
here I'm not doing anything you're not
stopping me you're not stopping me
Yorker what do you want me to do like
smack you in the mouth or what because I
can do that alright so as I said if you
haven't seen the movie memories of
murder it was one of bonk Jun has very
early movies you should probably check
it out cuz it's really really good
especially if you liked zodiac and it
takes some liberties with the case but
it's it's mostly kind of accurate so the
Hiwassee on the serial killer also known
as though Fosse on strangler was a
killer who murdered between 9:00
it was either 9 or 10 women from a
period spanning September of 1986 to
April of 1991 and like I said there was
a couple like more recent cases that
were sort of similar that were either
the same guy or maybe a copycat killer
but I'll get into that later
ok well let me say this right now that
span of murder that span of time is much
longer than a one-year tour of duty of a
[ __ ] American soldiers so I can think
we can probably pretty much it well I
think when you said that American
soldier you were more talking about that
was always dog boy skill that was just
like a one time
this was a serial killer yeah it was it
was almost a five-year span of his
murders and one person did see him which
I will get into in a minute okay and it
was it was definitely a Korean date okay
all right so as I said between 1986 and
1991 between nine and ten girls and
women were killed by this particular
killer now there was no particular age
range the youngest victim was 14 years
old and the oldest one was 71 years old
but they were all killed in the same way
they think maybe that the guy was either
going after a particular physical type
rather than somebody of a particular age
or he was just like an opportunistic
killer like he just wanted to kill
somebody because he generally would
attack them like while they were walking
home at night or something like that so
he was just like somebody that happened
to be walking past however old they were
he didn't really care now as I said this
happened in a pretty rural area this is
like a little city called hua Xiong
which is in and I know I'm gonna murder
this because I'm not Korean
but um the geonji province young ji Gong
ji oh yeah I was close yeah
now all the bodies were found within
about a two-mile radius actually more
like a 1.2 mile radius it's a pretty
small area all of the victims were raped
all of them were strangled with stuff
that they had on them like clothing
usually it was pantyhose or their socks
or something like that so this was a
killer that like I said was
opportunistic that's pretty typical for
security yeah it seems like he was
stalking and it was like a fetishistic
sort of he was just waiting for somebody
to come past he didn't bring anything
with him now some sources I saw like I
said there's not a huge amount of
information on these in English anyway
and you know I tried to translate the
Korean page on it and it just came out I
couldn't even read it so um I did see a
couple of I've read a couple of like
English language like Korean newspapers
that were talking a little bit about
this case like in the present day
because they were talking about
present-day murders and comparing it to
the old ones and they were saying
something like like some of the victims
had been stabbed
but I don't know if that's accurate or
not
most most of them I mean all of them die
by strangling almost all of them are
sharing with their pantyhose of their
bra or something like that you know
something that they had been wearing now
the first victim of this serial killer
this happened in September of 1986
September 15th and this was a woman she
was 71 years old and her name is Lee Wan
M and they found her body in a pasture
they usually found them either naked or
mostly naked just kind of laying there
and they had been strangled with like I
said bra pantyhose whatever now there
was another one less are a little bit
more than a month later October 20th
1986 this was Park Hyun sook she was 25
years old they found her body in a canal
now a little while after that and I
think this is about the right time like
I said not a huge amount of information
about this but right around the
beginning of December there was a woman
and I've never seen her named in any
sources so it might just be a case of
you know because she wasn't a murder
victim because she survived so they
might have been keeping her name like
under wraps because she didn't want the
publicity or whatever but she was
actually grabbed by this killer and
raped and left for dead but she survived
so she is the one and I'll probably show
it and I'll show it in the video so
she's the one that gave the description
of the guy like for the composite sketch
as far as I know there's no like one
composite sketch of the dude and she is
the one that gave it because she
survived the attack and this was right
around the beginning of December 1986
now according to her like I said it was
a Korean dude she said he was kind of
plain looking about 5 foot 5 he's you
know he's very average um in it's
interesting because in the movie they
said that he they talked about like how
soft his hands were I don't know if that
came from the actual Case Files because
if you see the poster and like I said
I'll put a picture up in the video if
you see the poster they have like the
sketch of his face and then they have
like a photograph of hands like crossed
in front of a chest so I kind of
wondered like I said I can't read Korean
but I kind of wondered if maybe that
soft hands detail was something that was
taken from the actual case because that
was kind of a big deal in the movie
where
they found this woman that had been
raped by this guy and she said like how
soft his hands were like as he had his
hand over her mouth and soon another
thing that this guy would do is I'd I
was workers I'm like that right so yeah
so they knew that probably he wasn't a
laborer or anything another thing that
this guy would do - and this they also
put this in the movie and as far as I
know this is accurate he would strangle
them with their bra or pantyhose or
whatever and then he would take off
their underwear and put it over their
head like a mask so like I said this is
very fetishistic now there was another
murder that happened on December 12th
1986 and this was Kwanzaa Quan Jung Hwan
she was also 25 and she was found down
an embankment and it was very close to
where the first victim the 71 year old
woman had been found and then two days
later another girl Lee ki sook she was
23 and she was found in a canal nearby
then there was another one only a couple
weeks later January 10th 1987 this was
Hong Jim young she was 19 and she was
found in a rice paddy very near where
the 1st and 3rd victims had been found
then there wasn't another one until
about May 2nd and that was Park Eun Joo
she was 29 years old and she was found
on a hill near the other victims also
then after that it was kind of a big gap
there wasn't another similar one until
September 7th 1988 this was on be soon
she was 54 years old she was also found
in a canal then there was another one a
little more than a week later September
16th Park sang hee she was 14 now this
one they don't know if this was the same
killer because this girl they like I
said they'd all been raped and strangled
same similar MO but this girl was not
found outside like I said she's only 14
years old she was found in her house so
they weren't really sure if this was the
same guy or not because the mo was a
little bit different so they thought
this might have been a copycat now a
dude was arrested for this particular
crime he was 21 years old and his name
was Eun Mo and he was arrested in July
of 19
eighty nine but they don't think that he
did any of the other ones they think
that maybe he just busted into this
girl's house raped her and murdered her
and then tried to kind of make it
similar to these other crimes so they
don't think this is the same person yeah
but this victim is usually tied in with
the other ones even though they caught
the guy that did this one then there was
another one in November of 1990 November
15th 1990 Kim me Jung she was also 14
years old just like the last victim had
been even though this is probably not
the same killer she was also found on
the side of a hill and then the
canonical last one happened on April 3rd
night and e1 this was Kwon soo sang she
was 69 years old and she was found on
the side of a mountain about nine
o'clock at night
same thing raped and strangled with her
pantyhose 69 years old
yeah well the oldest one was 71 the
first victim was 71 so like I said this
seemed like a crime of opportunity
motive death is always strangulation yes
no stabbings I think now one like I said
once worse that I saw said that some of
the victims were stabbed but I think all
the causes of death were strangling and
they were always strangled with pieces
of their own clothing always that's how
they knew that this was the same and
what kind of terrain we talking about me
this is in suburban areas or country
areas it's rural rural yes remain
community or I know exactly what they're
talking about that Korea is really only
one of three things it's either a city
it's a mountain or it's a rice paddy
that's it
yeah outside those cities it's a bunch
of roads that weave in between in
between mountains or along the sides of
mountains or down in valleys it's a
weird place when you see it you could
because everything is kind of
mountainous a lot of times you can't see
very far yeah so you could be sitting on
a patch of road and it might be at a
three-way intersection and you might see
200 200 meters up one street 50 meters
down the other Street and not see any
houses and you'd have houses in the area
yeah with the grass you know and so it's
kind of a weird terrain
visibility can be kind of spotty so what
we're talking about is that in those
areas be a good place for an ambush you
can sit there and wait yeah I'm kind of
feeling like that's what that students
doing talk to somebody gain their trust
or admit for a few minutes clock them
and then do what you got to do and then
get the [ __ ] out of there and not really
be seen now the way Korean culture was
is that the women were quite passive we
saw some [ __ ] on the bus going down to
[ __ ] soul a lot where we would have to
step in
okay here's a good example one time me
and my boy Webb we were going to we can
both got past at the same time weapons a
big old black guy well he was good to
have round two cuz that [ __ ] could
throw some fists we were in the middle
of the bus or we were in the bus on our
way to go to the train station we
weren't coming out of the D out of the
dmz area
Jim Jim GAC was in the morning we got
our pass early in the morning and school
girls got on a damn bus we're talking 12
13 year old school girls stand in the
morning in the middle in the middle of
the morning standing up in the middle of
the bus a bus basically vacant was old
drunk you know we look at our office
dude you know I mean with his suit on
and it's all on campus [ __ ] ties out
all night drinking and he's hanging you
know from the from the rail oh yeah I
can picture yeah and he's taking up he's
right dead center in the bus taking up
the whole aisle
man spreading he man spreading in the
[ __ ] side of the bus in an empty bus
yeah these little 10 12 year old maybe
13 year old that's sometimes it's hard
to tell he's local Korean girls they
look a lot of them look a lot younger
than they really were yeah but I could
what saying they were probably late
middle school meat you know I don't know
how their schools but this organized bit
part 13 you know yeah they walk by the
old they walk by the old dude and he's
grinding up on them as they're going and
trying to stop him as they're going
through and they're cowering trying to
get around him and not make our contact
with him he does like four of them like
that Webb jumps up there and I see
man web jumps up runs toward a cab miss
a boho and I'm right behind him like
that he grabbed that dude and snatched
him into him down in that chair like
that like just like that he's looking
yelling at us and huncle you call it
korean but we could it was called Hong
Kong I guess it means a han language you
know and he went there and saved him
girls what can that do yeah I mean well
what I was getting at is that Korean men
when they were behaving badly we would
see them intimidate Korean women like
that kind of [ __ ] throw their weight
around huh and they didn't really resist
they're very timid yeah so probably
that's what the kind of [ __ ] he was
doing it might have been here all right
he'd see some girl all right and thought
throwing his weight around and it was
just kind of cower and once they get
they once they kind of got compliant
he'd rape them then kill him although I
have to say that like you know being a
girl myself I've had things happen very
similar to what you're saying when I was
about that age and I have had things
like that happened to me as well like on
buses and whatnot yeah um and it depends
on the person I was kind of a shy kid
and stuff but I didn't really put I just
kind of like you know would run away um
I think over here you probably it'd
probably be more likely that a girl is
just gonna pop you right in the dick
over there you know the shit's a shy
Japanese girls stereotype you know just
like they were even more so in the area
like that and I can see one of those
dudes being kinda like that yeah and
trying to do that as soon as he's able
to get any leverage on her then he
starts going further yeah you know and
what was funny in that case like what
that guy was doing a guy here in the
West couldn't got away with that [ __ ]
probably I had I had to pull Webb off
that dude yeah these are
thirteen-year-old girls you know this
dude's in his 50s yeah you know although
like I said it doesn't shock me because
I had this Empire that's my thing and
honestly like I said even if you grew up
in America
if you're a girl yeah you probably had
similar years you know when you're a
teenager or lesson to you here's another
thing the bus was mostly dead but there
was [ __ ] middle-aged women and men in
that bus and they just watched and they
just didn't they didn't do [ __ ] yeah
yeah I feel like yeah over here you just
get your [ __ ] teeth knocked out oh
yeah the whole crowd would turn against
you
yeah they would just like beat you to
death probably and rightfully so but
yeah so I do feel like this is probably
like I said they only have one sketch of
this dude um that the the woman that got
raped and she survived and she gave the
police a sketch so the weird thing about
this so the guy they think that he when
the crimes were going on he was in his
20s or maybe early 30s so he could still
conceivably he's probably still alive
they think that he stopped after 1991
but they're not entirely sure why the
only thing they know about him like I
said other than having sort of a sketch
of his face knowing about what AG was
now I've seen they know that his blood
type I've seen both a be positive or be
either positive or negative like
different sources say different things
I'm like that's not super helpful
but that's about all they know like I
said they had semen samples from some of
the crime scenes but they didn't match
any of the suspects they had time
because they had a [ __ ] ton of suspects
but they never caught the guy and as far
as I know they never matched because
they had to send like the DNA [ __ ] like
over to Japan because only Japan had the
technology at the time to do DNA
profiling and Korea can do it but by the
time they got it back it didn't match
any of the suspects that they had in
custody now this was actually one of the
bits a pretty significant case because
as I said before you know they'd had
murderers they'd had like you know oh
these murders were probably committed by
the same person but they never had like
a quote-unquote serial killer where he
had like a very identifiable mo and like
you're immediately like oh this is that
guy again and this is like the first
time this had happened so they didn't
really have a lot of experience with
this type of crime in Korea because it
just didn't happen in this particular
way they didn't really have the
resources to deal with it now they did
evidently even though like I said the
cops were kind of short-handed at the
time this was kind of a rural area they
did expend a huge amount of time and
resources on this from what I've read
they'll see some of the sources say that
they had assigned two million cops to
that that's not there's not two million
cops in Korea I don't think that what
they mean is that it was two million
man-hours meaning it's not two million
people it's just you know however many
cops it was spending two million hours
on this particular case they actually
questioned over 20,000 individuals but
still they really still have no idea who
this was now one of the very
controversial things about this and I
might talk about this a little bit too
on the front boy's case too because I
think it was kind of the Frog boys case
that changed this law but for a long
time in South Korea murder had a statute
of limitations of 15 years which it
sounds very easy that would have made
sense in Korea but at the time they
justify I mean they had like capital
punishment and stuff like that but at
the time they because they didn't have
the technology they said life to old we
haven't caught you in 15 years they
can't prove it you know there's no way
we're going to be able to prove it so
what good is it going to do what they're
talking about it when DNA pried changed
all that yeah because after the Frog
boys case happened and you know people
were like freaking out about statute of
limitations and it was up in 2006 or
whatever and they're like look even if
they catch the dude now like now you're
not gonna put him in prison what the
[ __ ] so in 2015 they actually overturned
that now I don't know if they overturned
it across the board or just in these
particular cases of legroom you know
particularly egregious crimes but they
did actually overturn it
so they started like revisiting a lot of
cold cases after 2015 because you know
after they got rid of that statute
limitations thing now interestingly in
2004 there was a college girl who was
murdered in Cuong in a very very similar
manner
so people were said there was like a lot
of articles that turned up because I
found like you know at least three or
four articles talking about this
particular crime and then kind of
reflecting back on the plot song serial
killer case and speculating if this was
the same person or if it was a copycat
because like I said if it was the same
person I mean this guy say he was only
in his 20s then he would only been his
50s in the 2000s right 50s or some like
that so it's conceivable that it could
be the same guy or it could be somebody
that just heard about the cases because
like I said these are very high-profile
there have been several several movies
made about it
so it might have just been somebody
copycatting so like I said if this dude
did indeed stop in 1991 nobody really
knows why he stopped he'd be I don't
know if you can call him a copycat
because there wasn't much of a signature
there I don't you know I well the
signature rape rut and strangulation
with the clothing that's very very
generic you know well I don't like
something I could see out of Korea where
there isn't anything flamboyant or
anything real you know talk about unique
you know it's a very homogeneous culture
so maybe if a person goes serial killer
they can't do it in the most
conservative way possible yeah I'm
talking about somebody who's cutting
somebody's faces off oh did he underwear
thing you did the owner where he did the
underwear thing yeah like over the face
it sounds very conservative and that's
kind of the way they were yeah you know
Tom out yeah yeah it's like the bare
minimum yeah I see what you're saying
that's like a bare minimum serial killer
yeah yeah it's like just enough yeah but
like I said in other words it would have
been a very like almost like a square in
serial killer terms well he yeah he's
not I mean I'm not discounting like I'm
not right
yeah I'm not minimizing yeah I'm not
trying to like downplay the horrific
nature of what he did because like holy
[ __ ] it was like walking home one night
and we have mothers are [ __ ] yeah it's
like you know yeah this
like oh I cut the girl in half like in
Black Dahlia where I kept her chained up
for a couple weeks and tortured her and
for a couple weeks you know that's not
what you this is this is almost kind of
like basic math [ __ ] yeah yeah he's
lurking around kind of these rural roads
in the night he's wearing black clothing
everyone that saw him said he had just
had black clothing on
so he's like lurking around basically
like I said I don't think he had a
particular victim profile other than a
woman walking alone by herself at night
that I can jump on because like I said
it was teenage girls it was 20 year old
years it was 60 year old women 70 okay
see what you're talking about is a very
toned down Eastern crease turn version
of the Ripper yeah out the blood no
knife no knives no butcher in somebody
you know but it's just basically kind of
like the same thing you wander around
waiting for a victim yeah
and I'm a picture the terrain these days
you know I've seen so much of that
terrain I could see that yeah that'd be
a decent place to haunt well they think
that this is a fairly organized killer I
mean he probably had some particular
quote-unquote hunting spots because like
I said all the bodies were found within
less than a mile and a half radius yeah
the traffic isn't heavy
yeah Korea up there you know especially
towards the dmz areas you know you could
sit there on a road it might be good 15
15 20 minutes for a car to go up yeah
chances are it might be a military truck
yeah and they don't give a [ __ ] you know
I mean they're not really paying
attention to scent to civilians they're
thinking about other things yeah do they
saw you [ __ ] over a woman or
something like that yeah they'd to pull
they'd stop but they're just not not
alert for civilians right you know
they're not suspect it's not a
suspicious society anyway yeah they
don't think about that kind of stuff
yeah they're not God what's that gonna
do what's that yeah what's he doing yeah
now the interesting thing and I think
some people have kind of um put this
forward is a little bit of a theory but
this might have come from the movie I'm
not really sure because in the movie one
of the signatures that the killer has
not only he always attacks when it's
raining but he
always before he kills he always calls
into this particular radio station and
request this particular song and
actually in the movie it's like the only
female detective who everybody's just
like hey go get T [ __ ] or whatever but
she's actually a cop and she's the one
that says hey I listen to this radio
show and they always have this postcard
and this guy always requests this kind
of like obscure song and those are the
same days that the murders took place
so there was some rumors that actually
that did happen that somebody did call
in or sent a postcard to a radio station
requesting this particular song on the
days that the murders happened but the
rain thing was not some I mean two of
the victims were found like when the
weather had been rainy but as far as I
know the other ones were not so that was
kind of a thing that they came up with
the movie I think in the movie too they
said that he targeted women that were
wearing red and I don't think that was
necessarily the case either I think he
just grabbed whoever was sounds like a
random walking past like like his spot
you know what I mean it just seemed like
it was just waiting for somebody to want
I don't picture a guy like this being
picky I picture more being like
desperate that's kind of you know it's
like I feel like one this is a
fetishistic killer clearly this is
somebody that's like he's got particular
hunting grounds within this you know
mile and a half radius in this little
rural town
he's got good hunting areas he knows
that you know maybe at this time like
women are gonna walk by or maybe there's
like a bus stop or maybe like they walk
home from work or whatever I don't know
if he necessarily did any research
beforehand you know what I mean like
saying oh this is where women walk by
here sometimes I feel like maybe he
spent a lot of his time just waiting
like a guy in a duck blind do you know
what I mean he's just like waiting like
behind this hill or it's weird that this
guy is it's weird that this guy existed
because what's happening here is not
sexual I mean sex was easy to get in
Korea and I mean prostitution was legal
yeah so he's trying to kill somebody
this is hatred
yeah or either that or he's particularly
repulsive or maybe he he's been totally
rejected by women although like I said
from the sketch he just looks like a
normal looking dude oh my god he doesn't
look like he's not like Quasimodo or
nothing
yeah but he might be repulsive in uh
socially personality want us yet because
you know Korea is very status oriented
the money had something do with his
birth maybe he was illegitimate or maybe
he's something like this yeah this guy
definitely gives me the vibe of somebody
that's like I deserve women and I'm not
getting it so those [ __ ] Oh me yeah
I'm gonna kill I'm gonna take these
[ __ ] away [ __ ] them you know that
kind of stuff so that's definitely the
mindset that something like that that's
the vibe that I'm getting here sorry you
know they won't really know until you
catch them and you know what I mean I'm
not that familiar with the inner
workings of the South Korean mind on
that level yeah I mean but and [ __ ]
Americans that do this kind of [ __ ] are
hard to figure out so well like I said
any human that do this kind of [ __ ] I
mean like I said if you're a normal
human then that's good that you don't
understand that because if you didn't
understand it I'd be a little bit
because of the situation in Korea I must
say it's some kind of resentment for
rejection that's that's kind of the vibe
I'm getting it now from the little like
a glean from what people have like
looked into about this case they're
thinking he's probably psychopathic he's
probably like a young guy like you said
that it probably been rejected by the
opposite sex
they said that he shows traits both of a
serial killer but also a spree killer
because a lot of his early crimes were
very very close together sometimes it
was only like a week or two in between
but then there was like long gaps like
some of them there was like a couple
like in a really short span of time and
then there was like a year and then
there was another one or another couple
and then there was another year so it
seemed like there like I said they're
not really sure why he stopped they
don't know if he died maybe he committed
suicide maybe he you know went into a
mental institution maybe he went to
another country maybe they don't really
know um now I think a
to the one woman who survived he did
actually threaten her with a knife so
like I said maybe that thing I said
earlier about stabbing did have some
[ __ ] to back it up but he didn't seem to
have to use it though he just right yeah
he didn't really said that it just
seemed like he brought it along as a
threat because he didn't kill them that
way I mean as far as I know all of the
victims were the cause of death was
strangling could she identify like what
social class he came from whether or not
he was owned not that I ever saw like I
said I'd look was he a local farmer from
the area I feel like he almost had to be
from there because it seemed like he all
of the victims were drawn from this one
very small like rural community he lived
there then he must have lived there I
mean as he probably lived there and then
somehow resolved his issues moved away
and felt lucky that he didn't get caught
that's probably what's going on yeah I
do feel like that how old did she say he
was more or less she said maybe late 20s
she thought about maybe late 20s maybe
early 30s okay but no older than that
she thought he was like fairly young now
I should note like I said the guy that
got arrested for that one the 14 year
old who got raped and murdered and they
found her in the house he was 22 but
they don't think he was the same guy
that did all the other ones they think
that he was a copycat like he was trying
to really look like Korea is not a big
place if he moved away and continued to
kill they know about it tells me that he
somehow stopped what he was doing
yeah or died or died but probably more
like stop would they have a long
lifespan yeah yeah I mean it's not great
it's not that dangerous
well yeah like I said that's why this
was a big deal because they don't have
[ __ ] like this doesn't happen there the
danger there is military danger yeah and
you know you got three armors three
armies keeping it under control
and I think it's gonna be over soon yeah
I know the inner workings of North Korea
too pretty well and
kind of off topic but North Korea has
always wanted a peace treaty with the
United States you hear a lot of [ __ ] in
the media and it's a lot of his lies
after Kim il-sung died Kim jong-il his
main mission was to get a really
workable peace treaty with the United
States and I think that's gonna happen
they don't want to be a war forever and
a lot of [ __ ] that they've been doing to
their own people have a lot to do with
this war you know there's it's a train
wreck that country's a [ __ ] train
wreck all right
it made Nazi Germany look look all right
that's how bad they are
they're mutt they're worse than that but
you know once you have an entrenched
power structure it'll do anything to
stay in power and that's just what it's
doing but once they get that peace
treaty it'll unravel good
it'll unravel because I know how that
shit's gonna go yeah Dacus the ruling
class wants the assurance that they'll
be able to keep their money and in worst
case scenario escape to safety with
immunity at another country all that
shit's gonna be guaranteed to them
because they'll the the West and South
Korea will basically give them that in
order to resolve the problem because
that's how you're gonna solve those
humanitarian problems that it has you
can't blow those problems up you're just
gonna kill innocent people that's you
the North Korean people are basically
innocent they're they're occupied and
controlled by a medieval warlord really
that is enslaved them that with with a
with a religion too you know they have a
weird religion where they worship God
emperors it's not really weird what it
is its traditional that's how China was
during the goddamn brewer phase you know
that people
the Westerners look at what's happened
in North Korea they're just appalled but
if you look at it from the point of view
of a North Korean and say maybe like the
ancient Chinese what you see there this
is that's that's a traditional book in
Korean regime
you know that's how they've been for
thousands of years yeah you know you
could say South Korea is the weird one
if you want to look at it from the point
of view of traditional Korean religion
you know democracies didn't exist you
know the same with Japan you know they
had they worship the Emperor yeah their
own religions exactly like that yeah so
as I said now a college student a woman
was found dead in 2004 which there which
was very similar now there were also two
disappearances in late 2006 early 2007 I
also found this article now this also
happened in the same town wasseo now
what happened was this one woman her
last name was Park I've never seen the
first name given she was 52 years old
and she was a bookkeeper at a plastics
manufacturer and she left work and
disappeared and they saw they found that
her mobile phone they tracked like where
her mobile phone was and it had been
turned off about six miles away from her
company as far as I know they have not
found her now
December 14th of 2006 another woman
whose last name was Bay she was 46 years
old she had worked in a karaoke bar and
she made a call at her cell phone at
4:00 a.m. and then a few miles away the
cellphone was turned off she has also
not turned up so this you know this
article that I saw it keeps like
harkening back to the Hiwassee on serial
killer because they're like is this the
same guy is this a copycat because this
is very similar to like the same MO now
as I was like researching this there was
another case and this happened in 2016
so only a couple of years ago and this
woman who was 47 and her last name was
Kim for no first name given they found
her dead in a canal in May of 2016 now
she had been she was naked except for
her underwear
they found a bra and a jacket that they
assumed belonged to her that was like
a little way away my name is Kim her
last name was Kevin yeah he said oh okay
yeah no first name can't work in as
always what's funny is that there's only
like four last names well yeah I know
that's a very common last name but like
I said I shame a strong in park yeah
that that's it's you know but yeah okay
cuz I was going wait a minute hold on no
last name Kevin and I was like that is
the last name but you said first thing
okay no first name given no first name
given yeah that's what I said yeah um so
now this body was found about thirty
miles away now as far as I know I have
not seen any update on this case since
2016 they're not entirely certain
whether this was a murder I mean even
though she was kind of found just in her
underwear and stuff but they think that
the cause of death might have either
been drowning hypothermia or carbon
monoxide poisoning now she was found
mostly naked in a canal so drowning that
seat well that seems to suggest murder
yeah but they're not entirely sure now
they do note that she had had some
mental health issues she had been
treated for bipolar disorder she had
been hospitalized in 2005 so they're not
entirely sure if this was a murder or
maybe just an accident but like I said
because it happened in a similar you
know in at least within a few miles of
the other murders so they're wondering
not necessarily if it's the same guy
but if this is a copycat type of crime
this one I don't know about but the
other two women that disappeared that
seems a little odd to me cuz like I said
it seems like from what I know about
Korea and about their crime rate and
stuff like that this is very unusual and
like I said qua song is not a big place
so any women disappearing in this little
rural town that's gonna raise some
eyebrows whether this is the same dude
or whether it's just somebody like
copying that dude now like I said this
was kind of a big deal in Korea at the
time they've made several several movies
and TV shows about this best one like I
said the one I've seen memories of
murder which like I said that was Bob
bong joon-ho that came out in 2003 it
was also one called confession of her
murder
which came out in 2012 there was one
called gap dong which came out in 2014
there was one called signal which is
probably the second best known when that
came out in 2016 and one called tunnel
which came out in night in 2017 and
there have been a couple other ones too
so as I said go watch memories of murder
because it's really good like I said I
found a freezer on YouTube but you can
also rent it on YouTube if you'd rather
pay it's 399 but go check it out it kind
of is fictionalized but not that much at
least from what I can find out from the
case but it's interesting to me how not
known this serial killer is even though
he's killed at least nine people and it
seems like people don't really know much
about it and I couldn't really find all
that much about it
there was weren't I listened to one
other podcast about it but they didn't
have a lot of information about it
because if unless you can speak Korean
and I did watch the movie just so I
could get some kind of insight into like
the differences and stuff but they
probably catch him eventually I would
hope and like I said it have his DNA
they have his DNA they do but as I said
the suspects that they have questions so
far as far as I know have not matched
the suspects that they had like I said
in the movie they kind of showed them
like just picking up random
[ __ ] and beating them into
confessing yeah it depends on Korea I
mean I don't know if Korea has like a
National Crime Database where they have
a room where they can put they probably
do nowadays wherever they can put
everybody's DNA on yeah you know because
if you don't have a high crime rate you
don't have a lot of encouragement to do
that right do [ __ ] like that there says
well why should we put a forty million
dollars yeah it's like what it's just
one guy to catch like a couple of guys
yeah you know [ __ ] him they'll die off
you know it's that kind of stuff well
like I said in 2015 they did reopen like
a lot of cold cases just because of the
hole and like I said this probably was
because the Frog boys catch a case which
I'm going to talk about in the next
segment but just because they lifted
that whole statute of limitations on
murder
yeah thing so they did reopen a lot of
old coal
cases so we'll see if they do have some
physical evidence so maybe they can
match it to somebody like I said it's
somebody that lived there you know
whether he still lives there now or
whether he's dead I don't know but he
obviously lived there at the time
because that's who he was targeting he
didn't really go all that far so you
might have moved to one of the cities
yeah that's that's another thing he
might have moved away but like I said I
haven't seen any other similar crimes
coming up in other cities around there
which you'd think that that would come
up I mean he'd be in his 50s now a guy
can change a lot from that time so he's
probably like you know who I hope they
don't catch me it might be that cuz yeah
look what happened with the [ __ ] so I
did that was [ __ ] D'Angelo and it's
like nobody that and even the show that
we did about original Nightstalker
before
D'Angelo got caught and we worth it oh
he's got to be dead he's got to be dead
because like look at all of the [ __ ]
rapes and murders it's like 50 rapes
with that [ __ ] was 12 murders that
[ __ ] though he had all the same I
thought he was dead
he had all the senses of being the guy
who did that though yeah a little
coaster um because he was type of crimes
that he did was the rage monster crimes
yeah yeah and then when they find him
he's a mean old man you know if I could
yeah that's him
everybody did say that to you boys you
mean well even by looking at his faces
like he looks like a [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's like he just looks like he never
got a penis ever in his life I kind of
think this dude was like a beta like a
super beta kind of pervy kind of pissed
off in cell type guy yeah I mean I don't
think he's a badass I don't know I know
I don't get that feeling that at all I
think he's probably [ __ ] trying to
keep low and he's probably somebody you
look at he goes as am just some loser
one one thing that I liked about the
memories of murder movie is that like I
said because they haven't caught it had
a very um if you've ever seen the town
that dreaded sundown which was kind of a
loose adaptation of like the phantom
killer crimes it had kind of a similar
ending where the cop at the end the one
that thought that he could
see murder is just by looking at them
like there's a long shot of him just
like looking into the camera and the
director bong joon-ho said well he's
like that kind of serves a dual purpose
he's like one I wanted to show that like
he's looking into the eyes of the killer
but he's like also the dude that did
this might be watching this movie and
he's like so I'm trying to like be like
hey man I know who you are so you know
what I mean so he was almost kind of
like trying to and I was like oh yeah I
guess that dude probably did see this
moot because this was a hugely
successful movie how in Korea now the
survivor how how did she describe him
she said like I said I have a picture of
the you know she said that he was just
very plain-looking he was just like a
normal looking dude about 5 foot 5 kind
of a slim build okay exactly that's
generic Korean yeah he was just they
said he was just very ordinary getting
taller nowadays I saw she was ordinary
like I saw some some Koreans at the
Starbucks this suckers are over six feet
tall back at the time that I was in
Korea they're eating all our fattening
they're eating all that food when I was
in Korea you know you only likes Korean
special forces in like Korean marine
recon were that big yeah yeah yeah this
guy like I said he just looked like a
completely normal dude and I think
that's kind of like what bong joon-ho
was going for he's like because this
could be anyone so that's why he wanted
to have that final shot of like the cop
like looking out into the audience
almost like he's saying like I see you
she's describing that real random Korean
peasant stock from it from the [ __ ]
rice paddy family's yeah she's talking
like I said he has to be a local he had
to be a local why would he just forget
like that one tiny area five five a
hundred and thirty five pounds that's
usually what you're talking about and
yeah that's about how she described and
I'm not not athletic at all weak you
know that's man there's a great scene in
the movie and that this obviously didn't
happen in real life but it just amazed
me there's a great scene in the movie
where the cops like the two dumb cops
and then the one smart cop who's like
from the big city they decide they're
like oh well sometimes like the murderer
returns to you know one of the scenes of
the crime so they're gonna go stake out
the ship but they don't tell each other
about that yeah so like the two dumb
cops are over here by this one killin
Lloyd's Hill and like this smart cop is
ever here behind this other girl and
neither one knows that they're there and
while they're both there this one guy
comes like slouching into the area where
they had found this body however long
ago it was and he takes like a pair of
panties and a bra out and like lays them
out on the ground and then starts
jerking it and also he has like lacy
women's underwear on so they take this
guy into custody but it turns out that
he's just a perv he wasn't the killer he
was just like a guy that like got off on
the idea of it was a fetishist and yeah
and he just like liked the idea of like
I'm gonna go to this place where this
body was for like this naked body was
found and I'm gonna jerk off over it so
like they go yeah so there was like a
great scene look I didn't that [ __ ] the
place like Louisiana they didn't they
didn't [ __ ] said no you did it they
give him a [ __ ] bath well they did in
the movie too like that guy got beat
Richard and everything like that but
then they had to let him go because
another crime happened like while he was
in custody so but yeah it's a good movie
go check it out I haven't seen signal I
haven't seen some of the other ones
bread Tootsie memory supporter and I
definitely recommend it alright so we
are going to take a break right now why
don't we come back I'm going to talk
about another unsolved true crime case
from Korea the case of the Frog boy yeah
I like this one we'll get it yeah I told
you about this one so uh yeah I'll get
into why it's called that too
erroneously
I feel but we'll get into that after the
break we will be back in just a few
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look at that hello
where is she she said thank you see the
pookie can't see your face she's looking
at the camera you need to Caribou oh
goodness
where's your roll over look at that
belly just like a funny
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back you might see that
camera move that's cuz pucks got her
head rested up on the base of the
cameras yes she decided that whenever we
did the show she um she always says the
thing was like I'm gonna lay behind the
laptop yeah get up here and be a part of
the show
yeah so the shows to her she's the
audience back here looking at us good
like I don't really understand what you
guys do but you talk in this direction
so I'm just gonna you know like yeah I
think you guys are in here so I'm just
gonna like hang out in here because
that's what I do
yeah sometimes I'm talking I'm looking
at cookie cookies lookin at ya well
because well because I have to keep an
eye on her because otherwise she will
chew on the cord leading to the
microphone or the cord leading to the
camera so I have to like kind of
circumvent that by like giving her I
have these little a little chew sticks
that I bought for her that have catnip
on them so I have to like give her that
so I'm like please cheat this instead of
the cords because I don't want our
chewing words like bacteria on it she's
getting ready to fall back sleep you can
go to sleep okay all right so now we're
talking about another Korean true crime
case this is the case of the Frog boys
yeah
frog boys this weird [ __ ] here I told
you about this the other day when we
were walking this one's got me thinking
that might be American involved we'll
see this is possible because like I said
this is not a serial killer this was as
far as I know this was a one-time event
but also it's very strange
this happened in March of 1991 in Daegu
there have also been a couple of films
made about this now one was called
comeback frog boys this was made in 1992
which actually happened before the boys
bodies were found so they still thought
the kids were missing there was also
another room called children which came
out in 2011 now I tried to as I said in
the first segment you know I watched the
one about the WHA stealing serial killer
which was called memories of murder
I found that one on YouTube now somebody
posted the movie children on YouTube
also however it's in Korean
and the subtitles are Vietnamese which
doesn't really help me all that much
because I speak neither language yeah so
I kind of watched it but I couldn't
really follow it was going on so I'm
just saying but yeah now this happened
like I said the disappearance happened
in March of 1991 there were five little
boys no what year is this again 90 91 90
I'm good there were fine little boys you
chew all want who is 13 years old jo ho
yuan who was 12 years old
Kim Byung kyu who was 11 Park Chanin who
was 10 and Kim Jong sik who was 9 now on
this particular day I guess a lot of
people in this particular area I don't
know it was all career or just this
particular area um they had the day off
because there were elections that day I
believe it was a Tuesday because I think
I looked it up on a calendar so schools
were closed a lot of workplaces were
closed and things of that nature so
these five little kids decided that they
were going to spend their day off and
they were gonna go up in the mountains
and go look for salamander eggs and like
I said they came to be called the Frog
boys later because for some reason media
later said they were going up looking
for frogs are looking for tagged
tadpoles but actually as far as I know
they were looking for salamander eggs
alright and they just kind of came to
clean the whole time I was there never
saw salamander really yeah and I was
living down in them not even any of it
like digging digging foxholes or we come
free called fight positions you guys
call boxing you know what I did see that
yeah I'd say the weirdest [ __ ] I ever
saw in Korea Oh tell me
gigantic Hornet I mean how big was this
Hornet
head on that Hornet was about the size
of a nickel Mothra is that oh yeah
[ __ ] huge got stung by one of them
found another one dead Sossamon flying
that that Hornet must have been about
that big talking maybe two and a half
three inches long I've seen horchata
Ganic horns yeah
another one I saw as a soft we had this
bridge called his cross the M Jim River
we I think we wasn't the bridge of no
return do you think we just called a dim
Jim bridge yeah and I had to do two days
a damn guard duty on that thing before I
[ __ ] rolled out went back to the
United States and I was up there with a
bunch of South Korean troops we were
working together guarding that damn
bridge but a lot of it at night cuz we
shut it down
it was asleep all right man they had
this bug killer it was like this little
can they pull it out it was like a
little spiral you know like a spiral
there's a spiral shaped piece of like
incense so you'd light it it would burn
oh I know stuck but yeah so we got them
killed
I've seen those yeah kill all the
[ __ ] like citronella
yeah kill va's killed all the mosquitoes
yeah we have that here attended
mosquitos just falling out of the
[ __ ] sky man inside there we were
sleeping in a bus seemed like about any
inch of condemned mosquitos on the
bottom well what was weird about that is
around the around the the awning or like
you know the roof of the guard shack
this this bridge is gone they blew it up
all right that was really our part of
our job was to blow that bridge up yeah
because it was already wired with
explosives and if the North Koreans
invaded the what we were supposed to do
is blow the bridge up yeah okay okay so
that way they couldn't get across the
engine forever well that roof went over
there's like a little awning that comes
up when all around that guard shack and
that thing was infested with the [ __ ]
biggest spiders I've ever seen the the
asses on those spiders with biggest
ping-pong balls and totally round my
granddaddy's here in Florida yeah we
used to find I used to run we used to
run into those damn well they're not the
wolf spider type things that we have
here yeah they had long spindly legs I
don't wish to run it run through them at
night you know they'd set up webs in
between the trees yeah we'd be [ __ ]
through the webs yeah with your weapons
like goddamn we're just [ __ ] famous
you can hear the damn spider
run it over cross your jacket or hitting
the ground
yes [ __ ] spider well and I mean
growing up in Florida one thing that's
horrifying and maybe a lot of people
from other parts of the country don't
realize an insect only becomes
frightening when you can hear them
walking over something like in the
moment because in Florida famously we
have palmetto bugs yeah giant [ __ ]
cockroaches yeah and you can hear them
like sometimes you know my grandmother's
house which was built in the 1950s and
these big palmetto bugs we had all these
palm trees in the yard and they would
fly in in the night like trying to find
coolness because the air conditioning so
in the middle of the night you wake up
at 3 or 4 in the morning and you would
hear yeah across the wall and you would
know that there was a giant [ __ ]
cockroach in there and I have to tell
you I don't know if I told the story in
the show before but one night I woke up
and I heard that and I was like oh man
there's some [ __ ] in here and I gotta
wake up and kill it and then all of a
sudden I heard I felt a weight land
right between my tits yeah and it was
like oh it was a giant [ __ ] flying
cockroach and it landed like right there
was like [ __ ] oh I freaked the [ __ ] dude
check it was Oh was horrible I judge at
I was like oh no I'm sleeping on the
couch by here we got China cockroaches
giant hunting spiders what else
alligators snakes yeah it's it's fun all
right so let's get back to this [ __ ]
murder all right so now on this
particular day as I said there was an
election so a lot of [ __ ] was closed so
these five boys they actually had a
sixth friend whose name was Tyrone Kim
now they were all gonna go because they
had the day off they said well we're
gonna go up with our little buckets and
stuff we're gonna go up to the hill
where they usually went to play and they
were going to look for salamander eggs
now at the last minute tyronn Kim
actually got called back by his mom I
guess like she was like hey you didn't
eat your breakfast or something like
that or don't go up to the mountain with
it's like don't go it's too far or
whatever so he actually ended up not
going which was actually kind of lucky
for him in light of what happened later
so these fine little boys aged between
nine and thirteen set off to mount were
young to go look for salamander eggs so
they go up there and then hours later
their parents are like they come home
from work or whatever you know they're
like hey haven't heard from those kids
in a little while
wonder where they might have gone
because if something's starting to go
down it's been all day they've been gone
so the parents starts to look for them
and can't find them anywhere this is not
a huge area there's like a town there's
like a hill in between and there's
another town on the other side of it the
kids were very familiar with this area
they played on this hill all the time
they played they knew some kids in the
other town they were all from like the
same elementary school so it wasn't like
they just like wandered off and got lost
they were very familiar with this area
and they played here all the time so
none of them came home their parents
started looking for them they'd look for
them for hours and hours and they
couldn't find them and now it was
starting to get dark and they were all
starting to panic understandably so they
called the cops now the cops fan out
there looking for if they've got dogs
they got everything they can't find
these kids anywhere so these five boys
have essentially just disappeared now
because of that like at the time like I
said this kind of crime is very unusual
in Korea so this was like a huge like a
media sensation the cops they pretty
much like you know pull out all the
stops they got the dogs they got like
[ __ ] search parties they got
everybody some of the kids parents
actually quit their jobs so they could
look for the kids full-time damn you
know what I mean so this was like a big
deal the kids pictures were on
everything they were in the milk cartons
they have I even found a photograph on
google of like um you know how back in
the old days they used to have like
phone cards
you know with like minutes on it though
so yeah yeah and they had one of those
with all the boys pictures on it they
started calling the Frog boys because
they thought they were losers they
thought they were looking for frogs even
though it was salamander eggs funny it's
funny man you know just there are no
wild animals in Korea they ate them all
them all yeah you know we ate all you
[ __ ] the war and everything you know
the war on poverty there's their birds
there might be fish but they would have
you know the fish would have probably
been you know stocked yeah they eat
everything there was rumored that there
was a tiger in the DMZ but I think it
was [ __ ] you didn't see it I didn't
see it and I couldn't see how a tiger
could survive it's just one yeah too
many land mines
we're not been a damned woulda been a
damn breeding population and what would
it eat you know I need to see it yeah
this is what at anytime like anybody I
always hear reports of like oh there was
this one like wild animal cuz sometimes
you get like in the UK oh it's a black
wolf or something yeah like if there's
just one of them there's no breeding
population then I don't think how that
could happen
yeah but they yeah it was funny because
you know we were living outside during
most of time during that one year you
know doing feel problems we never saw
any animals other than birds birds man
sex just all gone like that it's just
that's just gone there's just everything
was just eaten huh because you know the
war in poverty
yeah and you know I don't think they had
any kind of controlled haunting you know
they did stock ponds with fish but
that's commercial right you know kind of
sad when you think about it true you
know yeah cuz [ __ ] I mean like I said
where we live in Florida where every
birds and [ __ ] on us well honestly if
you've released an animal into the wild
it was just a pet it will thrive here
because yeah the climate is so conducive
yeah so [ __ ] we were coming home we we
just ran up to the grocery store to get
orange juice and [ __ ] coming back we saw
a whole family of sandhill cranes yeah
we saw a big huge
we see bears all the time we see bears
all the time we saw a bear walking into
our neighbor's garage yeah hey bear walk
into my garage and look at me well if he
was sitting in the driveway yeah I was
sitting in the driveway yeah so we just
like everyone and like I go out for a
walk like every morning like on our you
know trail behind our house every
morning you see like turtles snakes you
know there's a pond that has alligators
and I've never seen them but I can hear
them they make that little call and
everything's [ __ ] birds everywhere
this yeah that's just animals everywhere
so it's weird to me to think that
there's funny though animals the koreans
knew we had a taste for beef but
beefless you know expensive in Korea so
that we had you know they would sell our
army food you know so yeah and the main
thing that they sold us really you know
buddy souls lots of cabbage you know if
I could cabbage all over Korea
she'd have slugs in it and stuff we need
it anyway great but yeah but thirteen
little-bitty slugs you'd have to pull
the cabbage head apart you know after
was cooking well you should do that here
too yeah as slugs love cabbage yeah yes
but the mean meat they sold us was
rabbit and that was really the first
time I've [ __ ] had rabbit it was when
I went to Korea and they gave me a half
of a fried rabbit yeah yeah I was like
what the hell go to the chow line
rabbit cut right down the middle
deep-fried it was [ __ ] good I see
rabbits it was good yeah I've heard I've
never had rabbit it's like chicken kana
they've um chicken with a pork texture
but I've seen it sold here in grocery
stores so it's not that on yeah it's
like it's not a huge like it's kind of
like an EVA it made sense for Korea
though cuz you know you don't need you
don't need huge grazing territory like
you need fur
yeah and then you don't need to worry
about pig pens and raising pigs you can
raise a lot of rabbits in this very
small area on very little my own
[ __ ] food ratted food deli pretty
million mean anything and this the
suckers ahead of that rabbit then
reproduce appraised they do you know I
would think that a rabbit probably
reproduces about as fast as a chicken
and you can't keep the number of
chickens under control you better eat
you some [ __ ] eggs you got chickens
you got more eggs than you can eat yeah
you know that's another thing too is
that you know the the path or you watch
and where we where we live is not it's
not super rural like they like to sell
it as well because it used to be used to
be roars now that yeah it's kind of like
yeah yeah but even now like I walk on
the the trail which is like you know
county owned and maintained you know I
have seen many bear wild rabbits I have
seen bears I have seen several snakes
many many many other animals and like I
don't know like I I feel like one
there's like there's bunnies everywhere
I guess yeah with that just the [ __ ]
that you saw out there yeah we got wild
animals armadillos possums that's the
thing I'm just saying that I see like
animals yeah all the time
yeah we saw turtle like I said rosters
everywhere but that whole time I was in
Korea living out in the field never saw
what I would consider to be our like a
real animal that's crazy
birds and bugs [ __ ] I was like I was
walking the other morning it was it was
between 7:00 and 8:00 in the morning I
saw a [ __ ] doe and a little fawn yeah
on the path like on the paved yeah path
and then they kind of ran behind the
bushes like when I came but yeah yeah I
asked him you know kim jeong-hoon yeah
yeah Kim Jong yeah what's his name yeah
Kim Jong no no I came showing this what
was his name
Korean Korean KATUSA I worked with I
mean I can't remember his name
[ __ ] drum thank you but they're all
named Kim there's only three names like
said but uh Kent I asked Kim I said
where are the animals man
you know I mean cuz what animals and I
said you know the heavy rabbits Amy dear
you saw outside now so there's no animal
to the war the war and yeah and poverty
they ate all the animals kind of shame
you know everything is because I'm
always like stencil is been busy I mean
even though it's Florida and there's
like animals everywhere I'm always like
super jazz like when I'm walking in the
morning and I see the deer I'm like oh
there we see like saying Hill cranes are
like like I said we're coming back from
the store today and I saw like a big ol
turtle a big old tortoise like on the
sides just that was in our neighborhood
actually and he was just like sitting by
the side of the road I want to sit once
peace comes to the Korean Peninsula I
don't see any reason why you couldn't
reach dock the peninsula they ought to
yeah animals are delightful you got to
have animals in your environment yeah
you know I mean that's just how I think
yes even though I have to say like not
mmm not to [ __ ] on any one of this
neighbor in a particular but they had
the animal control ended up having to
shoot a bunch of bears because people
complain to get vision and it wasn't it
wasn't in this neighborhood it was one
that was like about a mile away yeah and
a woman got um she wasn't killed or
really even hurt all that badly but she
was kind of like dragged for a little
while my favorite ball it was her fault
like she kind of like busted into the
garage and the bear was in there like
looking in her trash like berries will
do and the bear was trapped it couldn't
get around the car and it freaked out
and it it didn't yeah pushed her out
later but it didn't like it didn't hurt
her badly she just kind of like moved it
because it had a cub and she was from
another part of the world it was we're
talking about a Middle Eastern woman
that that's the story that I got she was
a Middle Eastern woman it really scared
the [ __ ] out of her and they called
animal control but I really and and
honestly like we saw there was a [ __ ]
black bear and those they're they're
clouds they won't they're gonna hurt you
and you're you deliberately [ __ ] with
them you can deliberately [ __ ] with them
and they want her
I got that [ __ ] on video people running
up to him and [ __ ] slapping on the
ground and well I didn't hear that
scarab life yeah I was walking the other
morning and like you know it was before
you got up so I was like it was 6:30
7:00 in the morning and I was walking
down the path and like I passed a couple
and they said oh there's a there's a
bear back there like watch out I didn't
see it but like we've seen bears up like
on the path and like I said we've had
them like turn up at our driveway and
stuff like that they're not gonna hurt
you and why not directly they're not
approached I mean they're scavengers
utterly yeah people think there's some
kind of apex predator like it's not a
grizzly bear it's not a grizzly bear
grizzly bears will [ __ ] you don't eat
your face but like black bears not so
much even that I wouldn't agree there
are some Grizzlies that have known they
can really be cool they're they're a
complex animal or sky to go up there and
hang out with the Grizzlies but
eventually you gotta run to a [ __ ]
mean grizzly that's just that out here
that's how it is you know you're rolling
it's Russian Roulette then it comes to
black bears black bears if I could run
first ask questions later if you see a
black bear or a brown bear the best
[ __ ] my best advice to you and this
is from personal experience go hey
what's up bear come here man come chill
out and just walk towards the bear and
try to greet the bear and the bear will
run well don't act like a like prey
never act like prey always act like a
friend and walk right towards them and
they will run which is kind of true of
like strange dogs as well yes I don't
like dogs will bite you if you try to
run away because you're acting like a
prey and gonna act confident don't like
a prey you don't act confident you have
to be confident there's a very different
is a big difference just go what's up
bear how you doing man you looking good
come here bear come on come on chill out
in that barrel run well like I said this
happened we were we were coming back to
it all time and this was the middle of
the day it was like not nighttime it was
nothing it was like middle of the
afternoon we're driving back from the
grocery store or whatever we're in our
neighborhood and I see a black bear
pretty decent-size one and he's just
moseying into one of our neighbors
garages
apparently because it was a fridge in
there cuz they can open refrigerators
I'm not Tom yeah so we see him and we're
like whoa okay well maybe we should stop
and like tell the people that probably
they should close their garage bar
because I've tried to talk to the bear
there's a bear she saw me trying to
reason with the bear so we pulled her by
this person's house yeah and Thomas like
what he's like hey bear what she didn't
like the bear is like oh [ __ ] yeah the
bear is like ok well I'm going over here
and like he left the garage and he walks
in I don't like dudes talking to me yeah
so then we went up to the people's house
and it was like this older it's like an
elderly couple I've seen him several
times because we passed their house all
the time yeah and we were like I don't
know if you know but probably you want
to close your garage door because
they're trying getting a Bears this
locked into your ground there's no order
trying to get into your garage
refrigerator they know what a frigerator
is because yeah well like I said they
know how to open car doors they know how
to open or refrigerators because they
know that there's food in there or that
there's somebody that can give them food
they're not stupid so I was like so
maybe if you don't want like bears
hanging on your part you might want to
like keep the garage door closed so you
know we we have like talked to that
couple a couple times subsequently they
are more intelligent than a dog and I
said I would think only only a little
bit less intelligent than a chimpanzee
but a lot better personality than a
chimpanzee I would say a personality
you're not quite they don't seem as
across no more more like a dog because
honestly like I said and I might have
told the story before but like one night
when we came home for the club and it's
probably like 3 or 4 in the morning and
there was a huge a very very large black
bear sitting in our driveway where we
usually park our car legs spread out
yeah yeah pull in today and we were kind
of messy we were [ __ ] up so we pull
into the driveway
yeah just like hey bear come over here
man come here man thank [ __ ] bear man
and that bears like ya know
yeah and I'm here not talking about a
little bear at that bear he was a very
large bear that bear stood up on his
back legs probably about six and a half
feet tall Oh at least a very big bear
yeah it was bigger than a big man yeah
but because we were like hey bear below
subs you know we were drunk like I said
we were kind of stupid so yeah we
weren't really thinking about getting on
it's the best thing eaten by a bear it's
the best thing like I said you're not
acting like praise so they're just kind
of like yeah I'm out of here but they're
not a predator either so they're just
like like I said I'm talking to you dude
I'm leaving the black but I mean then
the whole reason like we live in
Seminole County the whole reason why
they gave us these bear-proof garbage
cans was because they wanted to
discourage because that's what the Bears
rise out of here they try to get into
your garbage yeah and we had that the
other day because you had the bear-proof
garbage can but we had a lot of garbage
very similar to it in another thing and
the bear came and they're very similar
to a large dog yeah a large raccoon but
I would think that a raccoon is a little
more intense but you can make friends
with a raccoon two raccoons are cool man
so getting back on topic
on topic yeah what a contest so
off-topic sometime well I know like the
ladies they like it though a lot of
googling so these five little boys have
gone missing like I said so their
parents have like quit their jobs so
they can look for them full-time cops
are looking they're full-time like
millions of man-hours posters [ __ ]
these kids images were like on candy
wrappers they were on phone cards they
were on milk cartons it was just like
[ __ ] everywhere that was like a huge
deal now initially police were of the
opinion that these kids had run away
which
okay whatever move or that they had
perhaps died accidentally yeah no like I
said they disappeared in 1991 they
didn't find them until 2002 11 years
those bodies were out there for 11 now
so this is very strange to me because
okay so here's the thing
2002 September 26th
that's actually my birthday is it yeah I
guess he doesn't even know what my
birthday
yeah I know your birthday when it comes
up because I remind that yeah what's my
birthday July 1st damn is something
women women and their memories I know
don't joke right now - don't we suck the
way look I'm drunk I don't like I still
know when your goddamn birthday
do you really okay like I'm just gonna
go off on a tangent here we just saw the
movie A Midsummer MMH and one of the
plot points of this boiling anything
it's awesome it's it's it's not as good
as her like I feel like it's not as good
as hereditary but it's good like another
way I liked it better than her editor he
liked it better than her like hereditary
for real like traumatized me I had
nightmares for two I got a solution
I gotta see I had nightmares for two
weeks episode [ __ ] and that never
happens that never happens and you guys
know I love [ __ ] horror movies that
[ __ ] that stressed me out but this is
a good movie too but one of the plot
points in it was that the main
character's boyfriend did not remember
her birthday oh it doesn't [ __ ] and
remembered some other [ __ ] and then like
some bad [ __ ] happens because of that
I'm not gonna spoil it because it's it's
new out okay that's how these women are
man's how they do [ __ ] so I'm just
saying if we ever get kidnapped by like
some Swedish like pagan cult yeah I'm
not like making any promises about what
might go down I got [ __ ] serious head
injuries though in my past so it makes
me I can't remember no but I can't
remember numbers right but the thing
about it and I don't know what day is
today
half the time it sound good tell her man
but I have a hard time remember what day
but well okay like I can't give you some
leeway on that but um I'm gonna just say
right here I was married for a long time
yeah before and he didn't remember [ __ ]
either and he did not have a head injury
so I feel like it's maybe a dude thing
like this really damn work correctly
yeah like they can't remember there is
no correct or incorrect it's just a it's
a continuum I have just found that dudes
memories don't we sit here [ __ ] beat
me up in public ain't it I don't you
we're gonna have we're here to get all
kinds of subscribers that's all right
now I'm just saying I I'm not hating
like I see you know there's that there's
a huge like um you know spectrum of
different things but I feel like in my
experience like dudes I am known
memories not so good um be crazy well
they seem like nothing smart
gonna say [ __ ] be crazy they're
always picking on this man oh okay let's
give a good time right so these five
kids disappear we added this show over
with we're getting drunk and getting
drunk and doing all this side [ __ ] no
I'm just telling him I know the audience
likes this kind of stuff you know I mean
they like to see like oh my drama next
next we're gonna pick a fight with
another channel that's what we're gonna
do next
well you want to do that because you
want to yeah we're gonna pick a fight
with another yes we've talked to a
friend of artists yeah great I said pick
a fight with another champ
yeah and his advice was that well
because that's like kind of his job is
that he's a promoter yeah he's a
promoter for like various channels he's
like oh you should pick a fight and I'm
like man yeah it's like at one on a like
conflict in general and now I especially
don't like pointless conflict and I
don't like trolling I don't like any of
that kind of [ __ ] it's like you know if
you want to argue with me fine I'm just
like not gonna listen to you but
whatever but yeah this is a little Matt
little Matt's my [ __ ] boy but me and
him
little small little swamp you know a
little smoke that won't admit I already
mentioned a little smoke that's job his
job is to make with smaller channels big
right and you know he was kind of trying
to ask me for some money in a certain
way or he was kind of coming at me you
know I could probably help you what way
actually we did it well there's a bunch
of different techniques you know I got a
lot of a lot of good looking girls that
you know on Instagram and this and that
may share people need they start
promoting they help me promote other
people's channels and it works out this
and that need good work and that showed
in my channel because now you're doing
good man you got everything right you
know a lot of stuff he's doing is right
because and I said well then how could
you help me and he goes well I first
thing I'd recommend this I recommend you
to get in a fight with another channel
and I was like I was like yeah my
channel is bigger than yours once real
famous they call a bunch of [ __ ] and
[ __ ] calm wires and [ __ ] make fun
of them do whatever you can you know
you're good that kind of stuff Tom do
that you know [ __ ] with that other
channel and dillards probably respond
and next thing you know you'll probably
pick up half of their subscribers that
was a good advice man I was like it is
like yeah but I don't know I don't feel
comfortable cause like I work at
confrontational but like look if people
like say things that just like annoy me
but mostly I don't get mad I just get
like annoyed and yeah I just roll my
eyes at you or whatever but it's like
mostly I'm just like whatever shut up do
you and it's like I don't think about
you anymore so I don't what I don't um
I know there's no like a whole culture
particularly on YouTube that it's just
like oh it's like troll and like they
argue and stuff but it's like I don't
have time for that [ __ ] you see me start
to me to me it just seems very tiresome
and I don't have the time you see me
start [ __ ] with another channels
because like a little small did because
he told you yeah
a little small told me to see it's
implausible that I yeah I'm not gonna do
that because like I said one on
that into it don't think I'm gonna [ __ ]
with I'm not a vet personality type I'm
not an in a hurry I'm not I don't have
that personality this thing was well
make you grow quickly yeah yeah I'm not
a hurry no I'm not either like I said
this is we just I mean essentially we
started doing this for fun yes this was
never a job no like I have other shows
like I'm a graphic designer I write
books and [ __ ] like that we just do this
cuz it's kind of fun and a lot of people
kind of enjoy it you say that [ __ ]
though I started to bust it up I started
thinking yeah that pride would it would
yeah I'm sure it does work well that's
where you get your [ __ ] yeah cuz you
could be making a thousand dollars a
month on junk paid from I'm pretty
easily halfway there a little less well
gave me some good advice but it I don't
know if I'm gonna take it you know I
don't need the money that bad I remember
that night when he was like temp because
I mean this is just we know him in
person like he's not here
so we see him but he's not probably from
new you all he's from New York but he's
moved down here now yeah so we see him
all the time like or at least a month
every day yeah a couple times a month
yeah and I remember this conversation
from that night and I was just like one
I was drunk and I wanted to dance and I
didn't like want to talk about business
but also I'm just kind of like man I
want to do that yeah another one I don't
want to be an [ __ ] but I don't want
to do that little swirl comes from from
a wealthy family he does yeah his
parents own a company that does all the
damn landscaping for the [ __ ] people
that own the world I'm talking about
people that the lizard people like the
[ __ ] lizard people people in the
Manhattan Island that have their own
private theaters and underground [ __ ]
you know talking about [ __ ] he's told
me some [ __ ] bizarre [ __ ] stories
mansions were half of its underground
with [ __ ] theaters and [ __ ]
tunnels and they own [ __ ] houses all
over the world and he works for those
people that anyway
his parents have a house here also like
there was like a summer house
yeah and he decided to [ __ ] it who's
gonna move here he didn't like New York
anymore you sick of Manhattan and he's
coming in upstate new that was the Long
Island in a Long Island that's right
he lived in Long Island that's right he
was working in Manhattan right
no that and that that went I think this
were a lot of the cutter I don't know
yeah maybe yes you know we've known him
for years anyway
that [ __ ] moves down here gets the
[ __ ] floor the ID and there's a
resident seeing everything goes right
out and gets his [ __ ] CCW carry
concealed permit gets him in HK 360 365
[ __ ] pistol trying to hook himself up
with suppressors and [ __ ] he's [ __ ]
eating it up he loves it [ __ ] loves
it in Florida a lot of people from New
York move in here that's job well that's
been true for many years I feel like a
lot of people move here because of the
climate but just because they get sick
of the cold weather and there's less
true it's less restrictive here too it's
just it reminds me a lot of the way
California was when I was a kid yeah
yeah it's just cool here I like it
it's like California part two I like it
other than the weather
I hate too [ __ ] humid here weather
here I hate it and I was born here yeah
I'm from Florida I was born in Daytona
Beach Florida Halifax Hospital as you
learn it it's like you feel like a bro I
do not like and it's even though I was
born here I still hate it I have never
gotten used to it the humidity I hate it
it's worse here than it was in
Mississippi I hate it Dagobah it is deco
but it is oh we got to get back on Iran
tea so these five kids go up Lincoln
Priscilla metrics and they disappear
months pass years past it's like a huge
[ __ ] media surge these kids pictures
are on everything like I said they're
called the Frog boys because it's like
an erroneous perception but whatever
that's what they ended up calling them
now the only lead that comes about like
you know they investigate some kind of
like [ __ ] leads and stuff but there
wasn't really anything the only lead
that kind of happened in you know the
interim between when their bodies were
found was this guy calls in and
he says cuz there's always one guy
that's like has to like confess to
crimes he didn't commit
so this guy calls it he's like yeah I
kidnapped those kids for ransom and like
I held them and all this other kind of
stuff but they investigated that guy and
there was nothing to it now September
26th as I said that's my birthday
September 26 2002 now this guy is kind
of exploring around this hill he said he
was looking for acorns I don't know why
he was looking for those he was gonna
make stew out of it or to feed his pet
squirrel I don't know but he's like
looking for acorns on this mountainside
now he finds a bunch of little bones and
what looks like children's clothing so
he thinks that's a little odd so he
calls the police
now the police find the remains of all
five of the coin quit frog boys in a
shallow grave on the side of Mount Oread
now the strange thing about this is that
reportedly this area had been searched
several hundred times in the 11 years
since these children disappeared why did
no one find these bodies no one is
entirely sure now some people have
speculated that perhaps the bodies were
not there the whole time and maybe the
murderer kept them someplace and then
dumped them later on however um some
mold spores that they found on some of
the skulls suggested that the bodies had
been there the entire time you know
because they can tell plant growth and
mold growth and whatnot so they suspect
that they've been there the entire time
they just I don't know if the searches
were not particularly thorough or if
they were overlooked or whatever because
like I said I think they were kind of
buried now the interesting thing about
okay you know I might be able to explain
this okay
um when when did they disappear 1991 no
I mean what what season we talked about
it was March so spring
okay might have been that a monsoon
season happens sometime after that and
the Marten season yeah I been through
one of those I talk about the [ __ ]
Rain Man and it could have been that the
rain concealed the bodies at one point
or another oh yeah that's that's a good
point actually so I think that might
have had something to do with it because
I don't think the body feel like left
out on the surface I think they were
like kind of buried yeah so you might
have had you know there are a lot of
dirt roads in certain areas I had to see
exactly where this was mod abandoned oh
my goodness Pookie she jumped upon
instead oh okay could have been that
they were killed and fell down in a
ravine that rains some time and then
that slid them Millions let him down the
hill a little bit and concerned them
they might have fallen down the damn
pipe sometimes there's little pipes in
between and they were kind of tied
together one day yeah that was one of
the things that initially when they
found the bodies they were kind of like
bound together like they were all in one
area
yeah now initially what the authorities
believed was that oh well the five boys
got lost and you know it was only March
so they had huddled together for warmth
because of you know because it was
really cold out and they had died of
hypothermia and then subsequently become
buried under the hill now this was what
the authorities believed initially the
families did not buy this and a lot of
other people that were investing in the
case also did not buy it and they
requested or demanded I guess is the
better word
they're like please do a second autopsy
because we feel like there's you know a
murder case going on here so they did a
second autopsy and at the second autopsy
they found that at least one of the
skulls had two clear
bullet holes in the skull and a couple
of the other skulls also had signs of
some kind of trauma as though someone
had like cracked into the skulls with
perhaps quote-unquote a tool I've seen
it called you know maybe it was a
screwdriver or an
all or something like that that looked
like it had stabbed in the skull so
these boys were clearly murdered yeah
and kind of buried in one place because
another thing that under the parent said
was because look these kids played on
not worried off all the time it was a
town on one side where they were from
there was a town on the other side of
the mountain which was lighted up at
night it was like even it was nighttime
the kids would have looked and they
would have seen the lights they would
have known which direction to go so it's
not like they could have just like
gotten lost and just like died of
hypothermia all huddled together like on
this mountain where they play it all the
time they were very familiar with the
area it seemed far-fetched I want to
check when that monsoon season was again
it wasn't cold it was warm when monsoon
see yammer if it was the beginning of
summer
it wasn't the hottest part of the summer
I see the beginning of the end of summer
we might want to check on that one day I
don't know yeah well like I said again
disappeared at the end of March and they
weren't founded so that might Bend right
around monsoon season so somebody met it
killed them and then the monsoon sent my
medication like displace the bodies to
door she sealed the bodies or nothing to
have during monsoon season it's it in
that in that era a lot of those roads
going out to the country were dirt yeah
impassable during monsoon season so
there wasn't any traffic you hadn't have
found him there not where it was I had a
finally decided it see exactly where the
bodies were found
yeah but there's a lot of parts in Korea
even though the peninsula's not very big
where the traffic isn't very much I mean
you know your average Korean doesn't own
a car there you know kind of a most of
them are kind of a metropolitan people
they're living in a big city there's
public transportation yeah they're not
going very far they're walking so a lot
of them don't own cars did you start
going out into the rural areas there's
not a lot of traffic well and the thing
about it too is that I'm even thinking
about places in Florida even if several
hundred Pete
let's say hypothetically had gone over a
particular you know five mile square
area of Florida yeah I mean you could
miss yeah oh yeah well I mean it's easy
right it could easily happen there are
places here around where we live
let's just say if you dumped a body on
this on the banks of that dam rest off
the walking trail you know yeah and out
there yes second palm of the palm right
here the alligator yeah we hear the
alligators you could drop somebody up
there and end date sit out there for a
month
yeah probably no and this is a heavily
trafficked area like a lot of people
like it's not just our neighborhood this
is the little county if they weren't
actively looking for them they'd sit up
there and decompose and then once the
smell was gone you'd have no chance to
find in that damn boat yeah unless you
went down in there and do all that mud
so I do kind of feel like there's a
thing where people like oh well cuz I've
seen some sources say oh we searched
this hill like 500 times oh there was
like you know thousands of people
searching this area but that's the thing
it's like yeah you're searching this
area but one it's a massive area it's
kind of rural it's like you know [ __ ]
could easily be missed especially
something that you know the five bodies
were found in very close proximity to
one another it was just bones at this
point because it was much later so I
feel like it could have easily been
missed you know what I mean yeah um but
I do think these kids were murdered now
some people are lying thing is is that
the people searching don't know one from
area from the next so they kind of get
lazy well that seemed out here I've seen
a lot of diseases it's like you know you
don't do like a line like people will be
like a you know within arm's length of
each other and they're just like kind of
going through the thing but you're the
wrong person in that line at the wrong
time right if they're not really paying
attention or if it's just bones at this
point it's like it might be see it yeah
it might be some small bone that's like
easily missed especially if they were
partially buried and like you said it
might have been like monsoon season they
would have been partially washed on the
hill and buried I think mom's do not
even buy the person I had to check the
dates but man that monsoon season with
some
it's kind of equivalent to our version
of hurricane season yeah they just suck
in rains and rains and rains and rains
and rains you don't want to go out and
search during that shed yeah not the
early way Matt yeah I can get to you and
like I said those bodies were out there
if those bodies were out there during
that monsoon season they could have been
moved by the flow flow of mud I kind of
feel like that moment because like I
said because of them of the mold growth
they're pretty sure that the bodies had
been out there the entire time you know
which would suggest that the boys had
been killed very close to the time when
they disappeared and had either been
buried in a shallow grave by the killer
or were just left out and then were
subsequently we were out in the field
man to feel problems during monsoon
season we were miserable yeah whenever
the weather's the worst that's when they
used to send our unit out for [ __ ]
training that monsoon season if you guys
don't know imagine predator one bed
exactly without the predator but with
just a [ __ ] bunch of [ __ ] rain
miserable miserable just crush your soul
you [ __ ] sleeping out in that [ __ ]
sleeping in mud holes and [ __ ] yeah yeah
for like um you know our field problems
we didn't do this little three-day field
problems like this present no we did
like three and a half weeks three-week
field problems probably be out there for
nearly a month just I can live it living
out of what you carried on your back
you couldn't write you same thing it was
not the same time you know Jenny
that was a [ __ ] that was something
else that was an eye-opening it was a
traumatic experience
no I've kind of to this day I missed
that [ __ ] and I yeah you told me that be
can I talk to all my buddies from that
unit you know we've got a I still got
them on Facebook and we all [ __ ] love
each other and if I can remember those
times well it's your life together
forever well because when you go through
a traumatic experience together it's
like it's a bonding that you can't ever
really like replicate like in the end
quote unquote normal world
yeah and I just miss it I miss ya a lot
of people that miss I wish I was back in
it I've heard a lot of people say that
yeah
no conditions it's like it sucks at the
time but like in G I'd say I wouldn't
trade it for any amount of money yeah it
was like the ultimate rite of passage
well and your issue dudes they're like
your brothers now yeah well I've always
thought that too it's like yeah some
shitty stuff has happened to me in the
past but you can't go back and not have
that happen because you wouldn't be the
same person nowadays and there's another
thing I think you like who you are now
than you yeah and if you go through that
[ __ ] yourself and it has a certain
impact but if you go through it with a
bunch of dudes you know it has a totally
different impact totally different like
ice machine out of the Iliad or the
Odyssey yeah it's like a bonding exactly
that that is not um it's not easily
medicated it doesn't have this available
in civilian like relationships I can't
as young it was like a formative part of
my personality oh yeah yeah and I've
heard the same thing similar thing for
overdose for some similar situations
yeah okay so here's the thing about the
death of these so called frog boys as I
said even though initially they believed
this was an accidental death I don't buy
that but for a long time they thought
maybe this was more than one killer
because it's like this was a bookies
bushes that she's pushing the kid okay
so some people have speculated that this
was more than one killer because it's
like look this is five I mean there were
little kids but you know the oldest one
was 13 so it's like could one killer
really wrangle five kids at one time but
I don't know like from what I've seen
like most people believe this was a
single killer now
what some people have speculated is that
perhaps maybe the first murder or two
was accidental and then somebody killed
the other ones to like cover up for that
because there was a military firing
range very near to the site where the
bodies
found in fact there was like several
people that you know kind of frequented
this mountain found shell casings and
various other things you know in this
mountain because they that was something
those are everywhere though in Korea
that's what I mean so it's like did
somebody accidentally because the
shooting range on this particular day
because as I said it was a local
election so the schools were closed a
lot of workplaces were closed the
shooting range was actually closed that
day now some people have speculated
maybe somebody went on to this shooting
range like illegally like what after it
was closed and they were shooting and
they accidentally shot a kid or
accidentally shot two kids who were not
supposed to be in the area and then
freaked out and like killed the other
ones to cover it for it I don't know
that seems a little like overkill to me
look man accidental [ __ ] happened in the
area we worked all the time yeah we had
a damn truck say [ __ ] it and cut across
a field because they didn't want to go
through the intersection where the
stoplights work and run into a landmine
bullet and blow themselves up and killed
one dude you know man there was no
hiding that or anything it wasn't even a
big deal this is what yeah [ __ ] happens
and then the [ __ ] it goes on landmine
yeah lamb-lamb I see if a kid got killed
accidentally from a [ __ ] range they
would just chalk it up as an accident I
mean that's what I kind of had an LT get
killed in a rage at Fort Campbell for
some stupid reason where he crawled down
the side of an m249 saw range and got up
close cuz he wanted to see the rounds
hitting the target and he got hit in the
back of the head that was in my old unit
and that just on him that was on him but
he just went along like nothing even
happened yeah basically I'm like yeah
dumbass did the wrong thing and got shot
in the back of the head
yeah because he crawled out into a range
yeah crazy [ __ ] the kind of a stupid
thing yeah
and that's not a lie that's true that
was 1990 maybe three or four at Fort
Campbell no there's a guy from the three
to seventh I can [ __ ] pull up
he's online they'll tell you exactly
what that lt's name was yeah I think it
was I think it was second Battalion
three to seven there was some crazy [ __ ]
when we heard that we're like wait a
minute all out into the range why would
you do that he wanted to see what five
five six rounds look like up close
hitting those Mantor pop-up man targets
right but like could you later
it's he did it and they know they know
what saw or m249 saw like I don't want
to know where the round came from then
who didn't even tell the guy who shot
him cuz it was an accident
they didn't know that LT was downrange
in a damn pop-up target range although
you know what crazy [ __ ] that's what
sucks because like if that was me like
if I had shot that guy like even
accidentally
ya know man that's my stop now I'm
[ __ ] it's not a my I what's the name
of the [ __ ] the investigative team
it's not military tells what am I
thinking of there's a military as a
military and crime investigation I
forgot the name of that unit who does
that but they they checked all those
barrels out and evidently took that
round out the round got lodged up inside
his helmet it hit him in the base of the
skull went through his head hit the
inside of his k-pot and bounced back
into his head to head the bullet oh damn
yeah he was shot in the back of the head
because he crawled up with a [ __ ]
because he wanted to see what the rounds
look like it's just [ __ ] stupid I
mean but you know nobody's deserves to
get shot yeah but names like a stupid
thing right your passkey who was a spec
for he went green to gold and became an
officer and I [ __ ] friends with him on
Facebook and he's like dude you should
have seen the officer corps it was about
as bad as the enlisted Corps a [ __ ]
second lieutenant was just a private you
know I mean they had some more pull
but in this basically a guy knew in
service didn't crawl down onto a
live-fire range to see what I look like
why I can't tell you what
the thinking of the time of that guy got
shot in the back of the leg I said I'm
not I'm not get shot but like and if I
was the person that shot that dude even
accidentally I would feel bad like my
entire life when I first heard it I
didn't think it actually happened but
then I started hearing it from NCOs that
know that did happen yeah man and I
wasn't working yeah that lt over there
getting killed today it was like what oh
but so like you know we're saying all
that to say I'm not sure like I've read
a lot of blog posts about this like I
said this this has a little bit more
information about it online then the
kwangseok murders has but it's still
it's not a great deal of information
about it and so there's speculation that
I've seen it's like oh the most likely
thing is that somebody that was
illegally on that shooting range like
accidentally like shot one of the boys
or two of the boys and then like decided
they had to cover it up it's not like we
for the time I feel like that's probably
unlikely like though it seems likely
just because that was happening in the
area but I mean that it seems a little
bit like overkill like I but if you like
accidentally shot a kid yeah I feel like
oh let's shoot for more it's in like
yeah yeah yeah better it'll hold that
story I don't get in the United States
and lt crawled out into a live-fire
range and got [ __ ] accidentally shot
at the back of the head by his own
stupid decision and and and the world
moved on like it didn't even happen and
that was like manga like I said that
sucks
you gotta happened in Korea that's
happen Korea was even more balls to the
walls if some kids got accidentally
killed because they walked out into some
range this is when chocked up as a
normal Korean accident yeah it's just
wood even they stamp it on landmines all
the time they were doing all kinds of
weird [ __ ] like it's a quarry as civil
as the Korean civilization was basically
pimping out all their good-looking
pretty poor girls to the US Army to get
money back in to help rebuild their
economy this was not that kind of
civilization yeah I actually killed some
kids on range geez what a call
[ __ ] cop says I was shooting these
damn kids got on a rage and they were
him and they would have just right I
feel like that's gonna happen
because like I said I even saw this
[ __ ] horror movie on Netflix it's
called calibre actually you should watch
it's very good but it's like it's about
essentially the same thing it's like two
guys go hunting they accidentally shoot
a kid and then stupidly they make the
decision to cover that up and also kill
the kids dead because there's all the
other kind of [ __ ] government and I feel
like most 99.9% of normal people if that
happened you would report it because it
was an accident you didn't mean to shoot
that person you just got in the way it's
like it's horrible it would probably
traumatize you forever you might feel
like you wouldn't compound your error in
most by shooting four innocent children
most in addition in most cases that I
know they're like that involving hunters
and accidental shootings cuz the guy
that lived across that's a dentist or
guy that lived across my [ __ ] street
from my dad's house and in Mississippi
he shot he was a hunter hunting on his
own land he shot and killed a guy out in
the field and he called the cops and I
said because I shot this guy uh-huh-huh
in my property he's like she's he
pointed the gun at me well yeah I mean
and there were no witnesses and they
were just like okay well I guess that
happened well it just happened I mean
it's like him back in those days that
even that wouldn't have been the same
thing where we have to cover this up
because you accidentally killed a kid
not in Korea I kind of feel like Korea
they would have immediately go it can
range is an accident okay get the [ __ ]
out of here well that's what I mean so
that's what kind of like makes me it
leads me to believe that this was like a
purposeful yeah that somebody performs a
miracle like I don't know if like like I
said by the time they found them it was
11 years later so I don't think they
could determine like for example if the
boys had been like sexually assaulted or
whatnot but I feel like this was
probably that she was a murderer a
murderer yeah I don't think it was an
accident I don't think it was anything
like that and like I said I feel like
that's probably pretty likely even
though they don't have any like physical
evidence and how many kids was at four
five five five yeah you could cow five
kids so that is you plenty there were
little they were 13 there were four the
9 to 13 point a gun out of me hold one
of them hostage why the other ones have
to [ __ ] sit there with her face down
of the ground you could control
especially if you were a Korean male who
was older than them with military
experience and Koreans mostly have
military experience they're drafted well
yeah they have to serve like a certain
manner so you might have had a situation
where you had a pedophile you know I
mean who also had God and decide he was
gonna do his thing now the thing is kind
of suspicious but this case from my
point of view it's usually the kind of
guy that has the gumption to do [ __ ]
something like this doesn't stop that's
weird about this because this seems like
I mean the front boy's case is like
enormous Lee famous in Korea not so much
here like I feel like people kind of
know about it but it's not as famous as
some other cases but this seems like
something that was so specific that this
dude must have done other [ __ ] like what
I would have checked is I would have
checked were there any was there any
American connection yeah was there an
amazing service men on that area from a
military base now I'm kind of wondering
where he could gone out he was a [ __ ]
pedophile and he goes out and he either
has a god or a pickaxe or an ice pick
were they sure that they were shot with
a pistol in the head one at least one of
them was because they found two bullet
holes and they was talking about it was
like it was a shotgun essentially a
shotgun okay I know an American
servicemen really wouldn't have access
to a shotgun shotguns aren't military
weapons so that kind of is against my
theory that it was an American but not
that's I mean that is it would be tough
you know maybe he somehow figured out
how to get his hands on a shotgun to do
this yeah and maybe lose a sawed-off
shotgun something more portable like a
[ __ ] little pistol is fired a shotgun
cartridge or something yeah which I was
sure all right and some of them can be
homemade it could been maybe a homemade
shotgun in some weird way
and then he goes out and does this and
then ETS change the duty station be gone
forever that's what I mean this dude
might have killed other people in it but
in other countries it wasn't linked back
right like you said it in a way it kind
of like makes me lean toward that theory
because this crime seemed to be like it
was a big deal in Korea but that it
wasn't really repeated yeah it's almost
kind of like that guy was the guy had
timed it maybe he's like I'm out of here
in two weeks so I'm gonna do this man
yeah I kind of feel like that my name
and then like he went to and maybe he
did some [ __ ] in another country but
nobody thought to link it because you
know another thing there's a strong
possibility but I have to see where the
location were where the closest camps
were because they're a US military camps
all over Korea yeah and for somebody for
somebody to be able to leave the camp
and go out and roam the countryside
without being him you know what I mean
without being like watched or wiser
that'd be auspicious sure would mean
that he might have been from one of the
service and support camps where they're
not really tightly controlled maybe he
would have been yeah I mean I could wait
been an officer there was something
somebody who had you know low you know
like a lieutenant or something where he
would have had had the ability to leave
kind of like under his own authority
maybe yeah you know you'd have to see I
mean some guys that yeah some guys that
were stationed in the Seoul area and I
think even the Camp Casey area I don't
think they were as trying to controlled
as I was to where they could just leave
the camp and go downtown whatever they
wanted to I kind of feel like yeah this
second would like the first case we
talked about the quasi on serial killer
I I definitely feel like that was a
Korean that he was a local because he
targeted women in this one particular
area this case I'm not so sure because
this was seemed like kind of a one-off
in this area so I feel like maybe this
was somebody that wasn't from there yeah
um he might have been familiar with the
area but like he said he might have been
military and then after you know shortly
after this occurred he might have been
you know he might have moved to another
yeah place and he might have liked
reoffended in other places but no one
thought to lengthen to Brian my
experience of Korea wasn't the same as
the average guy that got deployed down
there yeah I mean I was in a high
security unit they didn't want us free
yeah walking around talking to people
Abuna I mean because remember I tell you
about all those girls and [ __ ] they was
throwing at us at all those clubs they
were also intelligence agents yeah they
listen to everything that he said and
they told their people there's Aaron
there's government South Korean
intelligence involved possibly North
Korean intelligence too
there's no way of knowing I heard some
stories from some other guys that were
there where it seemed like a girl was
trying to entrap them to entrap that
they might have been under the control
of North Koreans I don't know or maybe
they were under the control of South
Koreans I had a friend who is in part of
GSA which is a high seek higher security
area and a girl he was seeing regularly
I think he was a station didn't and case
can't was Seoul somewhere he wasn't uh
there's like a joint command and Seoul
and he showed me a picture of the girl
he was dating her gorgeous okay um she
tried to get him on heroin mm-hmm yeah
and then he reported that yeah all right
and then she vanished so yeah and what
we thought the army never told him it
Eric anything
yeah but why why that happened
afterwards then afterwards me and Eric
thought that what she was as she might
have been South Korean intelligence and
wanted to get him on some kind of lead
she was like so he would admit them says
so so she could control him and write
that as leverage over there today well I
feel like that's been gee it's amazing
yeah yeah sure allies spy on each other
all the time a lot people don't
understand that but I allies you know
Israel spies on us England spies on us
all the time they do
that kind of dirty [ __ ] you know to find
out I know what they're up to well they
want to know if we're keeping up our
side of some kind of a bargain yeah
that's usually what it's all about and
it's also just controlling power well we
were wondering if it was in North Korean
but I don't think it was I don't think
North Korea had that power I don't think
they had the connections to do it I
think was a South Korean or it might
have been a loyalty test for all we know
it might have been a loyalty test from
the Americans to see if he would report
her or not right so we don't know yes
but yeah so this case in particular like
I said a lot of the blogs I read seem to
think that like oh maybe it was somebody
on this range and they weren't supposed
to be there and they accidentally killed
one of the boys or two of the boys and
then like thought that it was easier to
kill five kids rather than like report
it I'm not sure I essentially buy that
because I think 99.9% of people would
probably report that because it was an
accident so I kind of feel like that's
probably not what happened
now there have been like some other
theories put forward mostly by a
criminal psychologist known as Kim Kim
Wong now he thought that maybe one of
the boys fathers was responsible for the
murders and that he had killed his son
and then killed the other ones to cover
up that it was him that had done it like
I said to kind of like make it seem like
it was a random person instead of him um
so this particular criminal psychologist
like kind of put this out there in Korea
and as there was no evidence for any of
the children's parents being involved in
the disappearance or murder of their
sons this criminal psychologist was
pretty much like blackballed he was
fired from his job and stuff like that
and as I said there is no evidence to
suggest that any of the children's
parents had anything to do with their
murders and I do kind of feel like
that's not I don't know it just feels
like it that's not the mo which I feel
like this was again kind of like we were
talking about with the serial killer
earlier
almost seems like this was a crime of
opportunity this was like some weirdo
that was like hanging out on this
mountain or whatever maybe he lived up
there maybe he was stationed up there
and he saw these five boys going past
and he's kind of like yeah I just like I
can I could get into that I could do
whatever like I said there is there's no
evidence that they were raped but
because they were it was 11 years later
there were skeletons at that point sex
had to be the motive so I feel like you
know just because they didn't have any
evidence of that doesn't mean that it
didn't happen I'm saying this is a
soldier they were all tied together
which to me suggests a little bit of a
fetishist yeah this is a soldier I think
and I'm gonna lean towards us a good
chance this might have been an American
soldier I'm saying that as a ex
Americans American soldier this sounds
like I mean there's a possibility this
could have been a Korean soldier but I
think this might have been an American
soldier
maybe because and the reason why I'm
saying that is because if it was a
Korean soldier probably would have
continued yeah that's what's weird to me
it's this seemed like a wanna I mean
you're killing five kids at once that
seems like something that would be this
might have been an American soldier that
[ __ ] had a bunch of [ __ ] problems
you know what I mean and he did his
thing and then he ETS and went back to
the United States right after this and
then he might have done some [ __ ] here I
just wish it here you know maybe he was
caught under a different you know I mean
you don't know but this just this is
very fishy I'm kind of likely yeah I'd
have to see the map and see where this
exactly happened where the camps were
around there but I would have think that
I would have thought that the Koreans
would have [ __ ] already already
assumed this the Korean I think now
whether or not they would have admitted
publicly that they thought it was out of
aerosols are probably not because they
were always worried about the alliance
yeah you don't want to like [ __ ] on
right right and it's like here here's
something that here's something that you
know them you know a lot of maybe
American civilians that have never been
involved with the Korean situation I
hear I'm seeing a lot of [ __ ] online and
then
these [ __ ] don't know what
they're talking about South Korea never
wanted us to leave they were making lots
of money okay we helped rebuild their
economy and the United States industrial
complex never wanted to leave North
Korea her she was CB South Korea we just
made a lot of money there you know all
this government contracts and I would
say we were only kind of partially the
good guys yeah we were protecting the
south but we were also kind of
preventing the south and the north from
resolving their problems all right we
were making money off of it and so was
the south we've kind of outstayed our
welcome it's time for us to leave and
let these Koreans [ __ ] sort this out
on their own I was there all right
Korea has a huge South Korea has a huge
army they can take care of themselves
yeah North Korea is [ __ ] pitiful at
this point they've starved down to
nothing you know the whole nuclear thing
I think is kind of a [ __ ] it's not a
threat to us only to South Korea yeah I
mean you can see why they're worried
about it yeah it's not really Arduino we
don't worry about we don't need to worry
it's not our business anymore on the
South Korean it's a big boy they can
take care of this [ __ ] on their own and
I think they just need to sign a peace
treaty let everybody chill out and let
and it'll take care of itself
generationally know about it might take
another 20 or 30 years but it'll slowly
work itself out well as old people in
their stupid ideas yeah during the time
I was there I would say it better during
the time I was there in the 90s I would
say that America was America's presence
was needed but I can't say that anymore
I think that situation has changed over
time and it's time for us to wrap that
up yeah and I think that'll happen soon
it's just situations change too much
South Korea is too strong they don't
need us there anymore yeah I kind of
found that yeah mom now
um as I said so like I said some of the
other theories about this when you mean
over the parents are involved there was
also kind of a weird theory I don't know
where this is because I don't live over
there but some people have said that
maybe there were apparently there is a
belief in Korea or among some segments
of the Korean population that if you
have leprosy then children's kidneys
will cure you so for a long time there
was like a there was like a rumor that
perhaps someone had killed that maybe a
leper or a leper colony had gotten
together and killed these children their
livers yes so that seems a little
far-fetched it is it seems very Park
South Korea is not backwards that's why
I feel like that's probably [ __ ]
yeah that seems like somebody like
grasping at straws yeah so as I said I
really do not believe that the parents
are involved in this now as of 2006 as I
mentioned on the first part of the show
where I was talking about the Hiwassee
on serial killer there used to be a
thing where you know the statute of
limitations on murder ran out after 15
years however the front boy's case
essentially it seems like it kind of
like changed the thinking on that
because a lot of people like flipped out
about the Frog boy's case and because
the bodies were not found for 11 years
and they were like look if the murderer
has found now like we can't prosecute
them that's [ __ ] so I feel like that
you know that that law kind of got
overturned either across the board or in
limited cases such as this so in 2006
the statute of limitations was said to
have expired on the Frog boy's case
however again in 2015 it seems like that
has been overturned they've reopened a
lot of cold cases including this one so
they are still kind of looking into
solving this case whether they will or
not I don't know but I do feel like this
was probably I'm leaning toward this
being not an accident not lepers not the
families I feel like this was a lone
weirdo yeah multiple murder that saw
these kids and it was like a crime of
opportunity I feel like that's probably
what happened
or it was somebody that was even like oh
maybe like a lot of kids because schools
were closed that day so they're kind of
like oh maybe they'll maybe they'd been
stalking them
there is a outside chance that they'll
catch just gave it probably not no DNA
yeah in this case as far as I know there
were no DNA because I as I said it was
such a long time between the kids
disappearing and them finding them
before we shut this down I want to give
you guys a recommendation I don't know
that we're always talking about movies
okay and without talking about horror
movies and mas room system there's a
[ __ ] movie you guys need to see and
you can watch it for free on YouTube
call pulgasari all right pulgasari
a North Korean movie made by Kim Jong Il
it was Kim Jong Un's father Kim Jong it
was a master of creation I had mastered
all forms of science all forms of art
also who create he created the world
right created the world sees and he a
[ __ ] defeated the but the [ __ ] the
other yeah yeah he actually instead of
going to the moon he actually brought
the moon to Korea that's right and he
did all kinds of [ __ ] like that okay
he made a monster movie okay like a
Godzilla movie called Booga sorry he
captured his favorite item yeah he
actually captured his favorite directors
to come and make this movie they made
the he made yeah pulgasari and poopoo
sorry is a [ __ ] little small monster
that grows when you feed him stealing
it's bigger and bigger bigger and he
becomes like Godzilla but it's happening
in medieval Korea it's like big man
Japan Viking expansion pan it gets
better when you he gets bigger yeah
sorry
with it they call him pukka sorry Oh
full this audio is actually capitalism
really that's what it is that the
monster you feed steel that gets bigger
bigger bigger you have to defeat it but
you can only defeat it to you only to
feed it through socialism people have to
call it bill is metaphorical - yeah
exactly for atomic weapon for atomic
weapons so go watch pulgasari you guys
will love I would love to have you know
for you know when you have like show
warriors in the Jumbos the two foot tall
Jumbo's he even had like I'm being he's
got some of those there any I got
arrived up right there let me show you
there up there yep
they even had a big Godzilla or Gojira
you know it's his real name alright dace
I saw somebody selling Apple sorry yeah
it couldn't have been North Korean
because I don't think the North Koreans
knew about merchandising this was made
in the very early eighties someone
probably just like made a replica but
but the thing is is that commies can't
copyright anything so I was really
thinking one of these days to make a
puka sorry a big two foot tall Booga
sorry blow-molded bull mold I can make a
shirt with it what are they gonna do sue
me I can't see you doubt it commies
commies can't sue well they can but I'm
[Laughter]
sure it took that cz-75 pistol and they
[ __ ] copy that [ __ ] everyone copyright
anything you can copy any make copies it
has like a real different approach to
that to intellectual property we have in
the way they don't believe in an
intellectual property well it's like if
you came a private intellectual property
belongs to mankind so they just can just
like do whatever so I would love to
[ __ ] make a pulgasari oh you ought to
get on yeah like I said I wanna make a
shirt like that and actually he's much
cooler than Godzilla it is an
entertaining movie I actually found a
quick shake I like Godzilla but he has
kind of a bull like face with big horns
costing a bull and a lizard and he's red
you remember that yeah Randy was filled
with some kind of molten stuff honey
they fill a molten steel I liked it
better than Godzilla oh that's it that's
a hot ache but he doesn't fight anything
giant though just fights a bunch of
soldiers fighting I I have a I have a
soft spot for the game
movies I have to say just because the
monster is he fought personally like it
was like yeah I have a knife for a head
yeah
and I shoot shoot throwing ninja stars
like you do yeah
alright so okay we're getting probably
drunk enough and that's it so let's wrap
up the show about Korean truth I hope
you guys have enjoyed this kind of as I
said we always changes these tangent
filled digressions into the cases of the
wah song serial killer and also the Frog
boy's murder case
so look more into it there's not a lot
about it in English but if you can speak
Korean then you'd probably get more than
that than I can also like I said check
out the movie memories of murder which
is about the boss and serial killer it's
very good alright so we are wrapping up
episode 151 remember if you liked the
show like share subscribe on all your
social media if you'd like to
financially support the show would be
much appreciated our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
or you can go to our blog 13 o'clock
podcast at wordpress.com and there's a
little button in the sidebar to a PayPal
account where you can give a one-time
donation if you would like to do so also
be much appreciated and remember our
regular episodes come out every tuesday
in our movie retrospectives usually old
movies come out every Friday we also
have 13 o'clock matinee new movies in
the theater that we review that comes
out every Sunday if you are a patron you
get early access to these 24 hours
before they go up live on YouTube so
check that out if you would like to do
so and we will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]